Hey everybody we've been doing this podcast for quite a while now and we're always kind of reminded of people who come on and kind of maybe for the first time listeners don't quite understand the format that we've created and I just kind of like to take this time and explain it to you. Are you, you sound like a pilot on an airplane like hey everybody I just want to let you know we're approaching Chicago, oh hair. I just thought I'd take it down because of the energy that they're about to be smacked in the face with by you.
大家好，我们做这个播客已经有一段时间了，我们总是会想起那些来上节目的人，可能对于第一次收听的听众来说，他们不太了解我们所创造的节目形式，所以我想花点时间向大家解释一下。你听起来就像飞机上的机长，说什么“大家好，我只想告诉大家我们正在接近芝加哥，奥黑尔机场”。我只是想把基调放轻松一点，因为你们马上就要迎面承受来自他的巨大能量冲击了。
Your energy is going to be lower, you're so low you'd have to rally to die at this point. I'm trying to balance this out, well I'm trying to balance this out because you are high on energy 24-7 so I'm just going to keep it like here because these people don't know what they're in for. Jason and I are in a fight apparently. So Will is doing a project, he's in Atlanta, so he's in Atlanta because I'm also in Atlanta working when I'm there, when I'm working, right now I'm not, I'm in Los Angeles but so Will said, so I'm going to be doing a project in Atlanta, Jason where are you living and
你的能量会很低，你低到这种程度，如果现在想死的话都得先振作一下。我试图平衡一下，嗯，我试图平衡一下，因为你24/7时刻充满活力，所以我打算把它控制在大概这个水平，因为这些人根本不知道等待他们的是什么。显然我和杰森正在闹别扭。所以威尔正在做一个项目，他在亚特兰大，所以他在亚特兰大，因为当我在那里工作的时候，我也会在亚特兰大工作，当我在工作的时候，对吧，现在我不在，我在洛杉矶，但威尔说，所以我要在亚特兰大做一个项目，杰森你住在哪里，而且
is it a good spot? I was like, yeah, yeah, it's a great apartment building so you should get a place there. So he gets a place there. In the same building. In the same building. Now Will is an attractive man and needs no help from anyone yet he is super passionate about keeping a fellow near him that is an artist with a comb I guess and you feel that you need some sort of hair help so he's got a guy with him, yeah, listen listener, travels
那里是个好地方吗？我就说，对，对，那是一栋很棒的公寓楼，所以你应该在那儿找个地方。于是他在那儿找了个地方。在同一栋楼里。在同一栋楼里。现在威尔是个有魅力的男人，不需要任何人的帮助，但他却超级热衷于把一个像梳头艺术家一样的人留在身边，我猜你觉得你需要某种发型上的帮助，所以他带了一个人在身边，听着，听众朋友，他旅行时带着
with a groomer and an assistant, no I'm talking. So he's got three people with him living in Atlanta and guess what, it's too crowded to live in the apartment with these three guys so while I'm out of town he asked me if he can use my apartment, yeah and you know who gave me the keys, you know who gave me the keys, yeah, Jason's Atlanta assistant because he's got a few, no, every city, every port he lands, he's got one here, by the way, let's not get into the fucking assistantship because you're assistant, do you want to tell me, do you want to tell listener? This is a work program, I am trying to help out doing your laundry is work, no, guys,
一个理容师和一个助手，不，我在说话。所以他带了三个人住在亚特兰大，你猜怎么着，和这三个家伙一起住在公寓里太挤了，所以当我在外地时，他问我能不能借用我的公寓，对，你知道是谁把钥匙给我的吗，你知道是谁把钥匙给我的吗，对，杰森在亚特兰大的助手，因为他有很多个，不，每一个城市，他登陆的每一个港口，他都有一个，顺便说一句，我们别扯什么助手不助手的了，因为你的助手，你想告诉我吗，你想告诉听众吗？这是一个工作项目，我是在帮忙，帮你洗衣服就是工作，不，伙计们，
you open up a fucking Pandora's Box Bateman and you'll never close it, so in the gay world they're called travel companions, yeah, so Will's a little top heavy on the travel companion so he needs to get away and stay in my place while I'm out of town and guess what this guy does, he starts taking snappies of little areas around my apartment and throwing them up on a group chat, snappies, yeah, so I go into Bateman's fridge and it looks like it, honestly, it was just different colors of like different flavored waters that have no sugar, obvi, yeah, and a couple other waters and then like half a yogurt, sugar makes me puffy, Will, and I sent a picture to Jason and to Jimmy, to Kimmel and Molly and to Thoreau
贝特曼，你们打开了一个潘多拉魔盒，而且你永远别想把它关上，所以在同性恋世界里，他们被称为旅行伴侣，对吧，所以威尔的旅行伴侣有点超标了，所以他需要离开并住进我的地方，当我在外地的时候，你猜这家伙做了什么，他开始拍我公寓周围小区域的快照，然后发到一个群聊里，快照，对，所以我走进贝特曼的冰箱，它看起来，老实说，里面只有不同颜色的、无糖的各种口味的水，显而易见，对，还有其他几瓶水，然后像是一半酸奶，糖会让我的脸浮肿，威尔，我给杰森、吉米、金梅尔和莫莉以及梭罗发了一张照片
saying just in case you guys are worried that Jason doesn't live like a total psycho in Atlanta, I sent him the picture and then I took a picture this morning because I was up there this morning, what were you doing up there this morning because you don't like to crap next to your travel buddy, I was using your treadmill, have you noticed that the monitor on your treadmill is a little like shaky when you run, yeah, it's noisy, can you fix that, especially when you're heavy, so I go up there, it doesn't shake that much when I'm on it, I look in the cupboard and it looks like a hospice, like somebody's dying, they're in their final days and it's just, it's like seated crackers, did you put that
说以防你们担心杰森在亚特兰大过着完全变态的生活，我把照片发给了他，然后我今天早上拍了张照，因为我今天早上在那儿，你今天早上在那儿干嘛，因为你不想在你的旅行伙伴旁边拉屎吗，我用了你的跑步机，你有没有注意到你跑步机上的显示屏你在跑的时候有点晃，对，声音很大，你能修一下吗，尤其是当你体重比较重的时候，所以我走上去，当我用的时候它没有晃得那么厉害，我往橱柜里看了一眼，它看起来像个临终关怀医院，就像有人快要死了，他们正处于最后的日子，里面只有散装的饼干，你把那张
picture up on the chat too, I'm saving that one motherfucker, I'm saving it and you know what I thought, I thought maybe I won't do it, but after this on air barrage, have you stayed off my toilet, have you stayed off my toilet, yeah, I haven't taken a job, by the way, if you have your own apartment, what are you doing in Jason's apartment, I told you, he's got travel companions, so they stay there, yeah, exactly, I've got my buddy Eli whom you know, yes, I know Eli, so I've got Eli with me, who's my pal and also works with me, some of us know how to travel alone, I've been there for 10 years alone, okay, sometimes I like quiet time, you'd like to be alone without people and then include your family
照片也发到群聊里了吗，我得存着那张照片，妈的，我得把它存起来，你知道我在想什么吗，我想也许我不会这么做，但是在经历了一轮空中轰炸之后，你有没有远离我的马桶，你有没有远离我的马桶，有啊，我没有拉过一坨，顺便说一句，如果你有自己的公寓，你在杰森的公寓里干什么，我告诉你了，他有旅行伴侣，所以他们住在那里，对，没错，我有我的哥们伊莱，你认识的，是的，我知道伊莱，所以我把伊莱带在身边，他既是我的好朋友也和我一起工作，我们有些人知道如何独自旅行，我一个人在那儿待了10年，好吧，有时我喜欢安静的时间，你喜欢没有人的独处时光，然后把你的家人
in that, you want to be alone, your hair is not that complicated, send Eli home, looks good though, doesn't it, yeah, it looks great right now, he's nowhere near you, right, he's right outside, are you kidding, did you do, did you do last looks for this little, no, you know what I did, I did, when I was working this morning doing some voiceover and then I went up to your apartment and I worked out and then I took a shower and I came back here and I'm going to, right after this I'm taking a snooze, another one, in my bed, how many channels do you get on that cable, because I haven't cranked that up yet, more than you've got at yours, you got the full package, I bet you got a pretty full package, that's
也算在内，你想独处，你的头发没那么复杂，把伊莱送回家吧，不过看起来不错，不是吗，对，现在看起来好极了，他离你很远，对吧，他就在外面，你在开玩笑吧，你刚才有，你有为这个小节目做最后的外表确认吗，不，你知道我做了什么吗，我做了，当我今天早上在工作做一些画外音，然后我去了你的公寓，我锻炼了，然后我洗了个澡，然后我回到了这里，我打算，在这之后我马上要小睡一会儿，又来一个，在我的床上，那个有线电视你能收到多少个频道，因为我还没把那个调好呢，比你在你那儿收到的多，你买的是全套餐，我打赌你买的套餐挺全的，那是
my handle in high school, Shawn, yeah, we have a guest here and it's Jason's guest and let's get to him, so stop interrupting please, sorry, sorry, sorry, all right, listener, God, payment's such a baby, better than apartment, shut your mouth or I'm going to take my key back, listener, we're going to have a conversation, oh yes, I've written this, listener, today, comma listener, comma, we're going to have a converse, shut up, we're going to have a conversation with somebody who you've never met, but you live with, a person you count on for your routines, your moods, your link to some of your closest and most intimate relationships, someone who if he drastically changed the way in which he did his job, it
我在高中的绰号，肖恩，对，我们这里有一位嘉宾，他是杰森的客串，让我们来聊聊他，所以请不要打扰，抱歉，抱歉，抱歉，好吧，听众朋友，天哪，贝特曼就像个婴儿，比公寓还好，闭上你的嘴，否则我要收回我的钥匙了，听众朋友，我们要进行一次对话，哦是的，我写了这个，听众朋友，今天，逗号听众，逗号，我们要进行一次对，闭嘴，我们要跟一个你从未见过但却天天与之生活在一起的人对话，一个你在日常生活中、情绪起伏时、以及在建立你与最亲密、最私密关系的纽带时所依靠的人，一个如果他大幅改变工作方式，会
would unsettle your emotional well-being and also the health of the financial markets, he loves sand castles, ham radio, taxidermy and hand gliding, he's got a very recognizable laugh, so shut up, he's recently converted from Virgo to Capricorn and this is his very first interview here in the United States, ladies and gentlemen, please welcome our friend and your housemate, co-chief executive officer and chief content officer for Netflix, Theodore Anthony Sarandos Jr., come on Teddy, I couldn't believe you started laughing, I saw Will stop there for a second like, why is that so familiar, what does that sound, Ted, it's so nice to see you, hey Sean, how are you, I'm good, you know, we had a dinner a long
扰乱你的情绪健康以及金融市场健康的人，他喜欢沙堡、业余无线电、动物标本剥制术和滑翔翼，他有着极具辨识度的笑声，所以闭嘴，他最近从处女座转成了摩羯座，这是他在美国的第一次采访，女士们先生们，请欢迎我们的朋友兼室友，Netflix的联席首席执行官兼首席内容官泰多尔·安东尼·萨兰多斯二代，来吧，泰迪，我简直不敢相信你开始笑了，我看到威尔在那里停顿了一下，心想，为什么这声音这么熟悉，这是什么声音，泰德，很高兴见到你，嘿，肖恩，你好吗，我很好，你知道的，很久以前，
time ago, Ted, long, many, many years ago, at our mutual friend, John Davis's house, which he's the best, and he, I said to you, I go, gosh, it must be so annoying, you must get so many people that come up to you on a daily basis saying, hey, what about this first show, what about this, constantly pitching you anything and everything for Netflix, and you said, yeah, well, you know, part of the job, but you know, it's what it is, and I go, wow, that must be something, and then literally, maybe two minutes later, I go, hey, Ted, what about this, I got a thing, no, I was going to ask you about that, Ted, because you're so, you know, I mean, you just, listener can just hear his laugh, you're
泰德，很久、很多年前，我们在共同的朋友约翰·戴维斯的家里吃过晚饭，他人最好了，他，我对你说，天哪，这一定很烦人，你每天一定遇到很多人走到你面前说，嘿，这个新节目怎么样，那个怎么样，不断向你推销Netflix的各种项目，你说，好吧，你知道的，这是工作的一部分，但你知道，事情就是这样，我说，哇，那一定很了不起，然后真的，可能也就是两分钟后，我说，嘿，泰德，这个怎么样，我有个点子，不，我正要问你这个，泰德，因为你太，你知道，我的意思是，你，听众刚才都能听到他的笑声，你
such a personable, warm person, doesn't throw up any sort of like barrier, like, please don't come talk to me, you're always very sort of inviting, I can't imagine that it was bigger and better than that, as far as you're warmth, before you became the man running the world, like has that, has that lessened, it has to, hasn't it, to keep people away? Someone asked me before, you know, what I get to do is big, and there's a ton of things to do all over the world, and someone asked me, I like the most about it, and weirdly, the thing I like the most is sometimes the thing I like the least, which is being pitched, I mean, I actually, the best part of the day sometimes is hearing an incredible pitch,
是一个如此随和、温暖的人，不会树起任何那种拒人于千里之外的屏障，比如请不要来跟我说话，你总是非常热情，我无法想象在你成为统治世界的人之前，你的热情会比这更大、更好，像那种，那种热情有没有减弱，肯定有吧，难道不是为了把人隔开吗？以前有人问过我，你知道的，我所做的事情规模很大，世界各地有成吨的事情要做，有人问我，我最喜欢其中的什么，奇怪的是，我最喜欢的东西有时恰恰是我最不喜欢的东西，那就是听人推销，我的意思是，事实上，有时候一天中最美好的时刻是听到一个精彩的点子，
it's almost like, decadent almost, that this is my job is to be told a story to, no, it's not great if I'm in the middle of dinner with my wife at a restaurant, and people do it, and that happens a lot, and I kind of feel for people that I think that someone gives them the really bad advice, which is, hey, if you ever see a person who buys TV shows, you may never see them again, so do it now. Let's pitch them, just get in there, get it out, get the idea out there. So to that, so you started, we can kind of get into the history, the history of Netflix a little bit, and your history with them, and I know that you've grown with the company,
这几乎就像，简直有点奢侈，我的工作就是听别人讲故事，不，如果我和我太太正在餐厅吃晚饭，而人们却跑来推销，那就很不妙了，这种事经常发生，我挺同情那些人的，我想是有人给了他们非常糟糕的建议，那就是，嘿，如果你遇到一个买电视节目的人，你可能再也见不到他了，所以就趁现在吧。向他们推销，直接进去，把点子说出来。说到这个，所以你开始，我们可以稍微聊聊历史，Netflix的历史以及你与他们的历史，我知道你是随着公司一起成长的，
and what was the first year, do you think, that you started hearing pitches on a regular basis, and how did it increase in volume, like did it pick up steam really quickly? Well, the very first pitch was literally someone walking out of the door at the end of a meeting, and it was the guys from MRC who we were meeting with, MRC also produces Ozark, Jason Bateman. What a show. Yes. What a show. Oh, you like it?
你觉得你开始经常听到推销是在哪一年，数量是怎么增加的，比如它是很快就火起来了吗？嗯，第一个推销真的是有人在一次会议结束时走出门的时候，跟我们开会的是MRC的人，MRC也制作了《黑钱胜地》，杰森·贝特曼。多棒的一部剧啊。是的。多棒的一部剧啊。哦，你看过吗？
Yeah, have you seen it? Oh, God, you got to catch it. No comment from you, Shawn. I have got to catch up. Well, we were, we were meeting with them about buying the rights to a movie, and literally while they're walking out of the door, they said, hey, by the way, we're going to make a new TV show, take it out to the market called House of Cards, and it's got Robin Wright and Kevin Spacey, and Bill Willamates, Oscar-nominated guy, wrote these three amazing scripts, and
对，你看过吗？哦，天哪，你得补补课了。肖恩，你没有评论。我得补补课了。嗯，我们当时，我们当时在跟他们开会，商量买一部电影的版权，就在他们往门外走的时候，他们说，嘿，顺便说一句，我们要拍一部新电视剧，正准备拿到市场上卖，叫《纸牌屋》，里面有罗宾·怀特和凯文·史派西，还有获得过奥斯卡提名的比尔·威利梅茨写了三个惊艳的剧本，而且
David Fincher is going to direct the show. Are you interested? No. And yeah. So, and I just, you know, it was funny, I had known the original House of Cards from its, seeing it on DVD actually from the BBC, and we had been talking about someday getting into original content and making original shows for Netflix. So I said, wow, if there's ever a moment to step in, if there was ever an unbelievably
大卫·芬奇将执导这部剧。你们有兴趣吗？没有。然后，是的。所以，而且我只是，你知道的，很有趣，我从它的原版DVD中就知道原版的《纸牌屋》了，其实我是从BBC的DVD上看到的，我们当时一直在谈论有朝一日要涉足原创内容，为Netflix制作原创节目。所以我说，哇，如果有一个时刻可以切入的话，如果有哪个节目是让人难以置信的、
perfect packaged show, it'd be this one. It's a great concept. It's great, great scripts. And then basically they asked us about hearing the pitch and we pitched them. Wow. So you, that was something that you and Reed had talked about doing down the road, and then they kind of dropped it on you and it sped up your process a little bit? Yeah.
完美打包的节目，那就是这个了。这是一个很棒的概念。剧本非常非常棒。然后基本上他们问我们要不要听推销，我们就听了他们的推销。哇。所以你，那是你和里德一直在讨论以后要做的事情，然后他们算是把这个砸给了你，加速了你们的进程？对。
I mean, we knew we'd do it at some point. I was always a little nervous that we'd end up doing it small. You know what I mean? Like people want to get their, you know, dip their toe in and then there's all original programming doesn't work because this show didn't work. And you went the other way. I went the other way, which I said, if it doesn't work, it's got to, I mean, let's eliminate that we made the wrong choices because this show was great.
我的意思是，我们知道我们迟早会做这件事。我一直有点担心我们最终会小打小闹。你知道我的意思吗？就像人们想要，你知道的，把脚趾伸进去试探一下，然后所有的原创节目都不起作用，因为这个节目没成功。而你们反其道而行之。我反其道而行之，我说，如果它不成功，那它也必须，我是说，让我们排除我们做错了选择的可能，因为这个剧太棒了。
And in order to compete with the other potential buyers, you guys had to really come over the top because as I think you've said before, like there were a thousand reasons for David and MRC to not do it with you guys. So you had to come in with two seasons, a hundred million dollars and kind of make it undeniable all the creative, you know, freedoms and autonomy that you guys have justifiably become famous for. Was that the moment when Netflix was most exposed as far as like, we're going to do it.
为了与潜在的买家竞争，你们不得不拿出压倒性的优势，正如你以前说过的那样，大卫和MRC有一千个理由不和你们合作。所以你们直接拿出了两季、一亿美元的预算，用所有合理的创作自由和自主权让这个项目变得无法拒绝，你们也因此实至名归地闻名遐迩。那是Netflix面临最大风险的时刻吗，关于“我们要做了。现在就做”？投入大量现金。如果我们能度过这次转型，我们就稳操胜券了。
Let's do it now. A big outlay of cash. And if we make it through this transition, the wins at our backs. The main one, Jason, is that they, we thought about, there's going to be a couple of things that we're, we thought about when we thought about, should we make original programming for Netflix? A big one was if everybody has all the same stuff, then there's going to be just a big race to the bottom, it's not a very interesting business.
主要原因，杰森，是他们，我们考虑过，当我们在思考“我们应该为Netflix制作原创节目吗”的时候，会有几个因素。其中一个很大的因素是，如果所有人的东西都一样，那么最终就会变成一场毫无意义的恶性竞争，这并不是一个很有趣的商业模式。
And how do you distinguish? How does any network distinguish themselves from the others is by their programming. And at the time we were just buying everyone else's reruns and putting them on Netflix. So this was like, at some point we're going to have to do this. And the other one was, if we believe that the world we live in today, where there's an HBO Max and a Disney Plus and a Paramount Plus, all those people are not going to want to sell us their programming anyway. So we better start getting good at it now.
你如何脱颖而出？任何网络平台将自己与其他人区分开来的方式都是通过他们的节目。当时我们只是买别人的重播剧放到Netflix上。所以这就意味着，在某个时候我们必须自己做这件事。另一个原因是，如果我们相信我们今天所生活的世界——那里有HBO Max、Disney Plus和Paramount Plus——所有这些人无论如何都不会想把他们的节目卖给我们了。所以我们最好现在就开始擅长制作内容。
You knew that was coming, even though you were in business with those people, you knew that there was going to be that tipping point where it was going to go the other way and that they were no longer and you were going to be their competitor. Now the foresight is amazing. And you're, so you guys, of course, have always been a subs business, you know, subscribers. What was your subscriber sort of approximately like when you first started making house of cards to today, for instance, whatever's public, you know what I mean? Yeah, yeah.
你预料到了这一点，尽管你当时和这些人有生意往来，但你知道会迎来那个临界点，事情会朝另一个方向发展，他们不再提供内容，而你将成为他们的竞争对手。现在的远见看起来太惊人了。所以你们，当然，一直是一个订阅业务公司，你知道的，订阅用户。当你们刚开始制作《纸牌屋》时，你们的订阅用户数量大概是多少，到今天为止，比如任何公开的数据，你知道我的意思吗？对，对。
So what's interesting about it is we started in the world, some people don't know this, but mailing DVDs around. So we were a DVD by mail service before we were streaming content. Sean, you're still doing that, aren't you? I still have a couple to have in return. You still got a couple? Yeah. They're coming.
有趣的是，我们起步于一个世界——有些人可能不知道这一点——是通过邮寄DVD起家的。所以在我们做流媒体内容之前，我们是一个邮寄DVD的服务公司。肖恩，你现在还在这样做，对吧？我手里还有几张没还呢。你还有几张？对。它们要寄到了。
They're coming. I'll send you a curry or over to pick them up. So then we started offering the streaming content to our DVD subscribers for free. And then later on we separated the two businesses. But it was before we started doing any original programming, we had about 25 million subscribers who were taking DVDs and streaming. And then, and then, you know, today we're at 204 million. Wow.
它们要寄到了。我派个快递员去把它们取回来。然后我们开始向我们的DVD订阅用户免费提供流媒体内容。后来我们将这两项业务分开了。但在我们开始制作任何原创节目之前，我们大约有2500万订阅用户，他们既租DVD也看流媒体。然后，然后，你知道的，今天我们有2.04亿了。哇。
204 million worldwide. Yeah. That's incredible. So, I mean, but is the math, I mean, I'm not a smart guy and I don't need the boys chiming in on it. There it is. If there are 7 billion people on the planet and you guys are effectively, as a result of your success, effectively a utility now, if there's 7 billion people on the planet,
全球2.04亿。哇。这太不可思议了。所以，我的意思是，但是这个数学，我的意思是，我不是个聪明人，我也不需要那两个家伙插嘴。就是这样。如果地球上有70亿人，而你们实际上，由于你们的成功，现在实际上已经变成了一种公用事业，如果地球上有70亿人，
even half of those people you would think would need the utility of basically television, if you guys are only at 200 million now and it is such an incredible success story, the growth potential for your company is, you can't even quantify it, right? And Ted, before you answer that, just how does that feel? You guys are making incredible content and Jason is now dubbed you a utility. Go ahead. You're like that fucking water and sewer. Well, could you be more successful than being something that people rely on like electricity
你甚至会认为其中一半的人会需要电视这种基本公用事业，如果你们现在只有2.00亿，而且这是一个如此不可思议的成功故事，你们公司的增长潜力简直无法估量，对吧？泰德，在你回答之前，这感觉如何？你们正在制作不可思议的内容，而杰森现在给你冠上了“公用事业”的称号。请说。你就像那该死的水和下水道一样。好吧，还有什么比成为人们像依赖电力或水一样依赖的东西更成功呢？
or water? I mean, you're like your TV. Yeah. I mean, like TV is today. And I think there's about a little more than a billion pay TV households in the world, the people who pay in some form for subscription television. And there's about more than 3 billion people with a mobile phone who watch content on their mobile phone around the world, you know, and they're paying for a subscription and they're
我的意思是，你就像电视一样。对。我的意思是，就像今天的电视一样。我认为世界上大约有略多于10亿付费电视家庭，也就是那些以某种形式支付订阅电视费用的人。世界上大约有超过30亿人拥有手机，并在手机上观看内容，你知道的，他们支付订阅费用，并且在屏幕上观看内容。
watching content on a screen. So when you think about addressable world, you know, we're only about 10% there. And then the other pieces of it will, you know, we'll keep growing in terms of the way you use Netflix today. A lot of people share their accounts with other people and all those kind of things. So it's at about 200 million people. We might have about 400 million watchers today. Wow.
所以当你考虑可触达的世界时，你知道的，我们只完成了大约10%的目标。然后其他的份额，你知道的，我们将继续增长，就今天你使用Netflix的方式而言。很多人与其他人共享他们的账号，诸如此类的事情。所以在大约2.00亿人的基础上，我们今天可能拥有大约4亿观看者。哇。
Now, in the seventies, especially on CBS, they had Saturday night, they had the foresight to everybody used to watch TV on Saturday night. Like it was like, you know, the New Heart Show or something like that or Carol Burnett. It was like this massive crazy lineup and the whole nation was watching on Saturday nights. Then the networks had the foresight to go, oh, wait, everybody's now slowly going out on the weekends. They're spending as much time at home at night on the weekend. So they had the foresight to change programming in that way to the week, right?
在七十年代，特别是在哥伦比亚广播公司（CBS），他们在周六晚上很有远见，过去每个人都在周六晚上看电视。就像《纽哈特秀》或者卡罗尔·伯内特秀那样的节目。那是一个庞大而疯狂的节目阵容，全国人民都在周六晚上收看。后来各大电视网有了远见，觉得，哦，等等，现在大家周末都在慢慢出门了。他们在周末晚上的家里花的时间一样多。所以他们有远见将节目安排调整到工作日，对吧？
To the middle of the week. And then what I think I keep coming back to is like Jason said, the foresight to know, to actually shift the human behavior, the watching behavior of the audience to now consume the way we consume entertainment. Like how, describe that like for house of cards, was it originally just like, well, we have to get into original programming. So let's just do one a week. Like whose idea was it?
调整到周中。然后我一直回想起的事情是，就像杰森说的，那种远见，去实际改变观众的行为、观看行为，让他们现在以我们这种方式消费娱乐内容。比如，怎么描述呢，就拿《纸牌屋》来说，它最初只是因为“我们必须涉足原创节目，所以我们每周播一集”吗？是谁的主意？
Like, wait a minute, let's shoot the whole thing. This is great. I love this answer. I dealt this answer. Tell him, Ted. This is the happy accidents of happy accidents, because I never even thought about it, Sean. When we finished this season, we're getting ready to launch. Somebody said, how are we going to put it out?
就像，等一下，把整季一次性放出来。这太棒了。我喜欢这个答案。我太喜欢这个答案了。告诉他，泰德。这是美丽的意外中的美丽意外，因为我甚至从来没想过这件事，肖恩。当我们完成这一季，准备上线时，有人问，我们打算怎么把它推出去？
They're already done shooting both seasons of house of cards, not both, but then shot out the entire first season and we had a meeting say, well, okay, well, how are we going to release them? What do you mean? And they're, well, you know, one a week, four a month. And they said, well, I don't, everything on Netflix, we got it a season afterwards on TV before and we put up the whole season. So I said, well, we can't have one show, one episode a week at everything else all at once.
他们已经拍完了《纸牌屋》的两季，不是两季，但当时拍完了整整第一季，我们开会讨论说，好吧，那我们要怎么发布它？什么意思？他们说，嗯，你知道的，一周一集，一个月四集。他们说，嗯，我不知道，Netflix上的所有东西，我们以前都是在电视上播完一季之后才拿到，然后我们把整季都放上去。所以我说，好吧，我们不能一边是一周播一集，另一边其他所有东西都一次性放出来。
Let's just put it up all at once and see how people watch it. And you were seeing the data on your service that people are watching multiple episodes of those full seasons that they were pulling down. And some people watch two, some people watch three, but nobody watched one. Yeah. Like nobody watched one a week. I wanted to have a conversation with Stevie Van Zandt at Lily Hammer before this, correct? Or was it afterwards?
不如我们就一次性把整季放上去，看看人们是怎么看的。而你在服务的数据中看到，人们正在狂看完整季中的多集内容。有些人看两集，有些人看三集，但没有人只看一集。对。就像没有人会一周只看一集一样。在这之前，我想和《莉莉海默》的史蒂维·范·赞特谈谈，对吧？还是在这之后？
And tell them how that went. Yeah. So Lily Hammer was actually our first original show that launched on Netflix. Our first deal was house of cards, but talk about getting a great pitch. I get a phone call from an agent who said, would you take a phone call with Stevie Van Zandt? Yes. Out of the blue.
告诉他们进展得怎么样。对。《莉莉海默》实际上是我们上线的第一部原创剧。我们的第一个交易是《纸牌屋》，但说到接到一个精彩的推销。我接到一个经纪人的电话，问我愿不愿意接听史蒂维·范·赞特的电话？好啊。莫名其妙的。
Yes. Exactly. Yes. And so Steve, I get on the phone with Stevie. He's in Norway and he went to Norway to produce this garage band album and somebody approached him with a script for a show about a guy who was just like his character from the Sopranos, who goes to Lily Hammer Norway to be in the witness relocation program. And he goes, yeah, I'm on board and he does it.
是的。完全同意。是的。于是史蒂夫，我跟史蒂维通了电话。他在挪威，他去挪威制作一张车库乐队专辑，有人带着一个剧本去找他，讲的是一个就像他在《黑道家族》里的角色一样的家伙，去挪威的莉莉海默参加证人保护计划。他说，行，我加入，然后他就拍了。
He plays this character. He produces the show and they didn't give him very much money. It's Norway. And he was trying to get a soundtrack money together to put music on the show. You got all the fish he can handle though, right? You got a great fish deal. Complementary. Yeah.
他扮演了这个角色。他制作了这个节目，而且他们没有给他多少钱。那是挪威。他当时正在拼凑原声带的资金，好在节目里放音乐。不过你可以吃到所有你能搞定的鱼，对吧？你谈成了一笔很棒的鱼的交易。免费的。对。
Complementary. And three bandanas. But by the way, no trailers in the middle of winter for a talent. They had to knock on doors and ask neighbors if they could use their houses. Oh my gosh. But anyway, so he tells me about the show and I go, great, can you send me a script? He goes, where do you finish? I'll send you the whole show.
免费的。还有三条头巾。顺便说一句，在严冬中给演员准备的不是房车。他们得挨家挨户敲门，问邻居能不能借用他们的房子。天哪。不过无论如何，他向我介绍了这个节目，我说，太棒了，你能把剧本发给我吗？他说，你还没看够吗？我把整部剧都发给你。
So he set the show. We loved it. And we did this deal to put it on. And then we told him how we were going to put it up all at once. He goes, wait a minute. Wait a minute. We just spent nine months of our lives making this show. You're just going to dump it out all at once?
于是他把剧发过来了。我们非常喜欢。我们达成了协议把它上线。然后我们告诉他我们要一次性把它全部放出来。他说，等一下。等一下。我们花了我生命中的九个月来制作这个节目。你们就打算一次性把它全倒出来？
And I go, yeah, just like an album. Just like an album. Yeah. Yeah. But it changed the world. It changed everybody's, now you don't even think about it. So Ted, kind of getting back to, I don't know, do you guys still, is there still the DVD business at all?
我说，对，就像一张专辑一样。就像一张专辑一样。对。是的。但它改变了世界。它改变了所有人的习惯，现在你甚至都不会去想它了。所以泰德，回到，我不知道，你们现在，还有DVD业务吗？
Or is that? There's a few million people who still take DVDs and I'm guessing it's, you know, parts of the country that don't have fast broadband or people of a certain age that are unlikely to adapt to new things. And then maybe it's for a hardcore, like if you're a real crazy deep movie lover, they still have everything ever published on DVD on that service. So, right. Oh, wow.
还是说？还有几百万人依然在租DVD，我猜，你知道的，那是国家中没有快速宽带的地区，或者是那些不太可能适应新事物的特定年龄段的人。然后也许它是为硬核粉丝准备的，如果你是一个真正疯狂的资深电影爱好者，该服务上依然拥有他们出版过的一切内容。所以，对，哇。
Okay. So that's where you start. So you started and you had started before Netflix, you were in the video business as well, right? Home video. Yeah. Back at the old video store and home video distribution. You and Quentin Tarantino worked out well out of that video story, video store nerds.
好的。所以这就是你的起步。你开始的时候，在Netflix之前，你也从事录像带业务，对吧？家庭录像。对。回到以前的录像带店和家庭录像发行。你和昆汀·塔伦蒂诺就是从那家录像带店里走出来的录像带店极客。
So you started that and then you, then you come on to Netflix and you continue in distribution and it becomes distribution of DVDs and then quite sort of organically kind of by, I know that you guys had this plan, but that just kind of happened. You start getting into content and you start being sort of the gatekeeper of all this content for Netflix and making all these decisions. And your guy who has a really strong, strong sort of encyclopedic knowledge of film and television, you know, there's, I don't think there's ever been a time where I've referenced something where you haven't gone, oh yeah, yeah, yeah, and you'll list like everybody
所以你从那开始，然后你，接着你，加入了Netflix，继续从事发行工作，它变成了DVD发行，然后相当有机地，通过，我知道你们有这个计划，但它就那么发生了。你开始涉足内容领域，并开始成为Netflix所有这些内容的把关人，做出所有这些决定。你是一个对电影和电视有着非常深厚、非常扎实的百科全书般知识的人，你知道，我觉得从来没有哪个时候我提到什么东西而你不会说，“哦，对，对，对”，然后你能把里面的每个人
who's in it. And so you went from that and then you became the guy who started to green light and all these like really great shows, these really top like, you know, quality programs and movies. Now you, of course, Netflix makes original movies. What was that shift like kind of going from distributor to sort of content provider and really overseeing all this great, you kind of be back your way into becoming a creative in a way. And that's usually the length of abatement question.
都列举出来。所以你从那个角色转变过来，成了开始决定为这些非常棒的剧集、这些顶级质量的节目和电影开绿灯的人。现在，当然，Netflix制作原创电影。从发行商转变为内容提供商，并真正监督所有这些优秀的内容，这种转变是怎样的，你有点阴差阳错地成了一个富有创造力的人。这通常是贝特曼式的长问题。
Yeah. I know it's true. That's from using my apartment, I guess, is catching. So you became the maker and not the seller. Yeah. It was, you know, in all fairness, we failed miserably at it first because we did a thing back when we were just doing DVDs where I took a bunch of money that we could barely afford and started a label for Netflix called Red Envelope Entertainment.
对。我知道这是真的。我想这是用我的公寓带来的，具有传染性。所以你成了创造者而不是销售者。对。说实话，我们一开始在这上面惨败，因为我们在只做DVD的时候做过一件事，我把一笔我们几乎承担不起的钱拿出来，为Netflix创立了一个名为“红信封娱乐”（Red Envelope Entertainment）的厂牌。
And that was the porn. Was that the porn? No, no. That is a good porn name too, though. But this was basically foreign language films, documentaries, indie film and some live stand up stuff that we recorded only for DVD to put it on Netflix as exclusive content. Was that live at the purple onion? Was that part of that?
那是色情片吗？那是色情片吗？不，不。不过这也是个不错的色情片名字。但这个厂牌基本上是关于外语片、纪录片、独立电影和一些我们专门为DVD录制并作为Netflix独家内容上线的现场单口喜剧。那是紫洋葱喜剧俱乐部的现场吗？那是其中的一部分吗？
Yeah. That was Zach Alfinakis. Yeah. And one of the first things we did was a documentary with Patton Oswald called The Comedians of Comedy. Yeah. And it was a documentary about their comedy tour of Patton, Brian Posayne, Rhea Bamford and Zach Alfinakis, who I was a huge Galfinakis fan and I didn't know anyone else who knew
对。那是扎克·加利凡纳基斯。对。我们做的第一件事之一是和帕顿·奥斯瓦尔特合作的一部纪录片，叫做《喜剧演员的喜剧之旅》。对。这是一部关于帕顿、布赖恩·波森、雷·巴姆福德和扎克·加利凡纳基斯的喜剧巡演的纪录片，我是扎克的超级粉丝，而且当时我不知道还有谁认识
him at the time. Yeah. I remember you were and that you're not now. I remember that. There you go. This is what I said at the past tense. I paid it. Zach, if you're listening, Ted hates your shit.
他。对。我记得你是，而你现在不是了。我记得那个。给你。这就是我用过去时态说的原因。我付过钱了。扎克，如果你在听，泰德讨厌你的破节目。
Well, in the middle of the production of the doc, Zach came in with this idea of a comedy special, which was basically going to be like a fake documentary about him traveling to do his show. And it was so, the pitch was so crazy. And I said, look, we don't really do all this yet. I'll tell you what I'll do. I'm going to give you a hundred thousand dollars and a camera and whatever you bring back, I'll put on Netflix.
好吧，在该纪录片制作的中途，扎克带着一个喜剧特辑的点子来了，基本上类似于一部关于他去各地表演的伪纪录片。这个点子太疯狂了。我说，听着，我们还没怎么做过这个。我告诉你我能做什么。我给你十万美元和一个摄像机，你带什么回来，我就把它放到Netflix上。
I promise. And it was Zach Alfinakis live at the purple onion. Wow. So, you know, you're nowhere near a doormat nor the people that are on your team. But that sense of creative latitude and freedom is something that you have been really consistent with. And your place is known for giving that kind of autonomy to the creatives. And it's a great recruiting element.
我保证。这就是《扎克·加利凡纳基斯：紫洋葱现场》。哇。所以，你既不是个逆来顺受的人，你的团队里也没有这样的人。但那种创作的自由度和宽松度是你一直以来都在坚持的。你们的地方以给予创作者这种自主权而闻名。这是一个很好的招聘亮点。
It's a sincere position that you take. Like if we're going to hire creatives, let's let them do the creative work. It seems like such a common sense policy and position. Why is it that you think it is so rare in the industry? I think, you know, it's an offshoot of the executive philosophy and Netflix, too. You know, hire the best people and give them the tools they need to do the best work of their life. And then get out of their way.
这是你们采取的一种真诚的立场。如果我们雇佣创作者，那就让他们去做创意工作。这似乎是一个极其符合常识的政策和立场。为什么你认为它在行业里如此罕见？我认为，你知道的，这也是Netflix高管哲学的一个衍生品。你知道的，雇佣最优秀的人，给他们完成一生中最好的工作所需的工具。然后别挡他们的路。
It's just something about human nature that people feel like they need to add value to everything no matter, you know, if they do or not. And I think the idea and I would always have a lot of friends like you guys who tell these horrific stories about network notes for television shows. And I always think, man, if I was ever in that role, I'd hate for people to be talking about me like that or my company like that. And I was thinking about this idea like, who has a better idea of what's funny than the funny person you hired to make this show.
人性中似乎有这样一种东西，人们觉得自己需要对每件事都发挥价值，不管他们实际上有没有用。我想这个理念是——我总是有很多像你们这样向我讲述关于电视台节目审片意见的恐怖故事的朋友。我总是想，天哪，如果我处于那个角色，我可不希望别人这样议论我和我的公司。我想过这样一个想法：谁能比你为了制作这个节目而雇佣的搞笑的人更懂得什么是好笑的呢？
Right. Right. It's such a common sense concept. And by the way, do you ever have this fear that you're going to become that Netflix once you guys become, you're very successful now, but you become so successful that you end up becoming like the status quo, that that starts happening, the culture at Netflix. Is that something you have to kind of stay on top of? Always.
对。对。这是一个如此符合常识的概念。顺便说一句，你们有没有过这样的恐惧：一旦你们变得非常成功，你们最终会变成那种Netflix，变成现状，这种文化开始在Netflix内部滋生。这是你们必须时刻警惕的事情吗？总是如此。
I don't, I don't imagine any of the folks we're talking about wanted to end up doing this. Right. I think there's something they made a left somewhere where they should have made a right. Right. And I'm constantly thinking about how do you make sure we keep that spirit alive? How do we make sure when I had somebody who made a documentary film for us recently who made one back in those early red envelope days.
我不，我不认为我们谈论的任何人都想以这种结果收场。对。我认为他们在某个地方向左转了，而他们本该向右转的。我一直在思考，如何确保我们保持这种精神的存活？如何确保——我最近有个纪录片导演为我们制作了电影，他曾在早期“红信封”时期制作过一部。
And when they came in, they said, I have to tell you that it felt about the same. Yeah. Which was a huge compliment. I just, I'd love to hear that. Ted, I don't know if you remember, you and I had a conversation. We can use this or not, but about somebody that we both know who was working for you. And I said that this person comes from that world. They had come from a more standard studio world and network world.
当他们来的时候，他们说，我必须告诉你，感觉差不多。对。这真是个极大的赞美。我只是，我很乐意听到这个。泰德，我不知道你是否记得，你和我有过一次对话。我们可以用这个或者不用，关于我们俩都认识的一个为你工作的人。我说过这个人来自那个世界。他们来自更传统的制片厂世界和电视网世界。
And you had said, I said, is it tough? Do you have to kind of break them of those old habits? And you said, yes. I do. Absolutely. Yeah, you do. Absolutely. And I do think it's one of those things where it's like, I've had someone on our team basically
然后你曾说过，我说，这很难吗？你得打破他们的旧习惯吗？你说，是的。我必须这样做。绝对的。是的，你必须这样做。而且我确实认为这是那种事情，就像我曾让团队中的某个人基本上
say something along to the effect of they couldn't get into the writer's room to meet with the writers. And I said, well, this showrunner must not think you add much value. So that's really on you. That's really on you. You really have got to. Wow. Because I've never met a creator yet that didn't want to have a great collaborative
说过这样的话，大意是他们进不去编剧室去跟编剧们开会。我说，那这个剧集主管一定觉得你带不来什么价值。所以这真的是你自己的问题。这真的是你自己的问题。你真的必须。哇。因为我从未遇到过不想进行一次伟大的合作性
conversation. Right. That really didn't want to figure out, is this working? But there is that dynamic where a creative person will quickly sense whether the note is coming from a place where they're sort of assessing a false negative on what you're doing because they're giving you a note to try to get you to do it the way that they had always imagined it would go as opposed to the note coming from a place of trying to help you do what they think you're trying to do, right?
对话的创作者。对。他们真的想弄清楚，这行得通吗？但确实存在这样一种动态：一个有创造力的人会迅速察觉到，意见是否来自于他们试图对你正在做的事情进行错误的负面评估，因为他们给你的意见是想让你按照他们一直以来想象的方式去做，而不是来自于试图帮你去实现他们认为你正试图做的事情，对吧？
So it comes from a place of helpfulness is the good note as opposed to conformity, which is the bad note. Right. And it really is consistent over there with you guys. It's great. We'll go to SuperMeta, talk about one of your other episodes, but the interview with Ron Howard, I love that. And I thought his, what his comment was, is that I'm not looking for a different idea.
所以好的意见来自于提供帮助，而不是来自于强求一致，后者则是坏意见。对。而且你们那里的这一点真的很一致，很棒。我们要去超级Meta聊聊你的其他剧集，比如对罗恩·霍华德的采访，我太喜欢了。我认为他的评论是，我不是在寻找一个不同的点子。
I'm looking for a better idea. Yeah. Right. That's great. I love that. Yeah. I think I got that. Yeah.
我在寻找一个更好的点子。对。太棒了。我喜欢这个。对。我想我是这么理解的。对。
Because different is disruptive. Better is additive. Yeah. It was great. Because there was a million difference, you know, they're all good. What is your opinion about? I would love to hear your opinion about the network system, because it seems like the pilot system is kind of broken and like, so listen, our pilot is sort of like the audition
因为不同是颠覆性的。更好是增量性的。对。太棒了。因为有数百万种不同，你知道，它们都很好。你对什么有什么看法？我很想听听你对电视网系统的看法，因为试播集系统似乎有点崩溃了，比如，听着，试播集有点像试镜
episode. And if everybody likes it, then they order more episodes. Yeah. Sean, how could you leave that out? Sorry, Tracy. Sorry, Tracy. That's usually your, I can't believe you'd be so irresponsible. Sorry.
剧集。如果每个人都喜欢，那么他们就会预订更多的剧集。对。肖恩，你怎么能把这个漏掉？对不起，崔西。对不起，崔西。那是你通常的，我不敢相信你会这么不负责任。抱歉。
That's wrong. My sister in Wisconsin. So, so because the business model, I don't understand, explain it to me and, and where you think it's going. And is it just like a cycle that can't be broken at the networks where they shoot all of these, they spend all this money shooting, all of these pilots are buying these scripts and then they make 10 pilots and then they pick one and, and then that one doesn't work. And then, and, and now the audience is now onto them.
那是不对的。我在威斯康星州的姐姐。所以，因为这个商业模式，我不懂，请向我解释一下，以及你认为它将走向何方。这是否只是一个在电视网中无法打破的循环？他们拍摄所有这些东西，花巨资拍摄所有这些试播集或者买下所有这些剧本，然后他们制作10个试播集，接着挑选一个，然后那一个失败了，然后，而且，现在观众已经看穿他们了。
Now the audience I feel for, and it seems like for sitcoms, especially, they'll put like two or three on if they don't get a number to pull it off. So the audience goes, I'm on to you. If you're not invested, how do you expect me to be invested? That's why I'm going to Netflix because Netflix is invested. Yeah. A lot of these tools that were built, I think we're all like figuring out safe ways to say no.
现在我觉得观众已经看透了，对于情景喜剧来说尤其如此，他们会放出两三部，如果收视率达不到就砍掉。所以观众会说，我把你们看透了。如果你们自己都不投入，你们怎么能指望我投入呢？这就是为什么我要去Netflix，因为Netflix是投入了真金白银的。对。建立起来的许多工具，我认为我们都在寻找安全的方式说不。
You know what I mean? Like, and I felt like I'm always trying to figure out how can we possibly say yes to the, how can we figure out how to make this work? And I think the pilot, you know, again, for the audience, they shoot one episode, they test it with sometimes like 15 or 16 people. And if they didn't think it was funny, they don't do it. And I felt like, well, that's seems crazy. Who are these 16 people?
你知道我的意思是？比如，我觉得我总是在想我们怎么才能对这个说“好”，我们怎么才能弄清楚如何让这个行得通？我认为试播集，你知道的，再次为了观众，他们拍摄一集，然后找大约15或16个人来进行测试。如果他们觉得不好笑，他们就不拍了。我觉得，这听起来太疯狂了。这16个人到底是谁？
And that's just a weird offshoot of the way they test screen movies. And they'll just go to a shopping mall and find a hundred people who have nothing to do but go sit inside of a movie theater. And then those hundred people decide the fate of this sometimes a hundred million dollar investment. That seems insane. So I feel like what we can do is say, let's bet on the creatives, let's bet on ourselves. When we say yes, you know, we, we may say yes to a full season or we may say yes to
这只是他们测试电影试映方式的一种奇怪的衍生做法。他们会去购物中心找一百个无所事事的人，让他们去电影院坐坐。然后这百来人决定了有时投资上亿美元的项目的命运。这看起来太疯狂了。所以我觉得我们能做的是，把宝押在创意人员身上，把宝押在我们自己身上。当我们说可以时，你知道，我们可能会对整季亮绿灯，或者我们可能会对
a little bit more development, but I never want to do like a pilot and then see how that thing work. Cause I just see how our own shows evolve from the first episode to the last. If you watch a, you know, the famously the Seinfeld didn't do it, it took four years. Cheers. Cheers. Mary Tyler Moore. James Brooks said that Mary Tyler Moore was not Mary Tyler Moore for four years.
更多的开发阶段亮绿灯，但我从来不想拍个试播集然后看看效果如何。因为我亲眼见证了我们自己的节目从第一集到最后一集是如何演变的。如果你看过，你知道的，大家都知道《宋飞传》当年就没拍好，花四年时间才走上正轨。《干杯酒吧》、《干杯酒吧》、玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。詹姆斯·布鲁克斯曾说过，玛丽·泰勒·摩尔用了四年时间才真正成为了玛丽·泰勒·摩尔。
Yeah. Right. And there's that kind of, and I think that Jason and Sean will agree with me. They've probably been part of shows before that are you just preemptively disagree. Yeah. Yeah. Both of you. Sean and I both passed.
对，没错。而且这种，我觉得杰森和肖恩会同意我的看法。他们以前可能参与过这样的节目，你会本能地先反对一下。对，对。你们俩都这样。肖恩和我当时都拒绝了。
There's this kind of you, there, there is this sort of adversarial relationship between creatives and the networks often until you kind of prove it and you become a big success. And then even then, then they're playing catch up and it's like, now we're going to fuck the studio and we're going to try to get more money. There's never a great dynamic there. It's always, it's always adversarial. And of all the shows, every time I've worked with you guys, whether it was on a restaurant or a Bojack or flake or whatever, there's never that relation, that relationship is
这种你——创意人员和电视网之间往往存在一种对抗关系，直到你证明了自己并大获成功。即便到了那个时候，他们也还在疲于追赶，感觉就像是：现在我们要去搞垮制片厂，我们要设法争取更多资金。这种动态关系从来都不太好。它一直是，一直都是对立的。而在所有的节目中，每次我和你们合作，无论是《发展受阻》还是《马男波杰克》或是《流浪富豪》还是别的什么，从来没有过那种关系，那种关系
always really solid. You're regarded as a partner truly and I'm not, I don't even mean that in some sort of BS fucking way. I mean that, that for real, like, Hey, let's check with Netflix and the notes that come from you guys never come like, Hey man, you guys have, it's always like, Hey, did you guys think that maybe Bubba and you go, Oh yeah. Yeah. Yeah.
一直非常稳固。你真的被当成合作伙伴，我不是在开玩笑，也不是在说那些废话。我是说真的，比如，“嘿，我们去跟Netflix确认一下吧”，你们发来的意见从来不会是，“嘿，老兄，你们这集得……”总是像，“嘿，你们觉得芭芭拉可能会这样吗？”然后你会说，“哦，对，对，对。”
No, I think it's like, I just feel like it scales better at last longer because remember I came into this business as a fan. Yeah. I didn't grow up in the business. My dad didn't do this. So did John. Yeah. I'm still a fan.
不，我觉得这就像是，我只是觉得这样的规模效应更好，能维持得更久，因为还记得我是作为一个粉丝进入这个行业的吗？对。我不是在这一行里长大的。我父亲不干这个。约翰也不是。对。我依然是个粉丝。
I also think the audience might get a sense that there is, you know, the fact that there's no ratings and that you guys for many probably great reasons keep all of that information in house. You don't share it with any of us that makes stuff for you guys. You'll imply, you know, it's, it's kind of doing well or not doing well perhaps, but it's really sort of like, if it's not doing well, it's gone. But if it's doing well enough to stay on, it stays on. There's no sort of teeth gnashing about, Oh, the ratings were up or down today or tomorrow.
我也觉得观众可能会感觉到，你知道的，因为没有收视率，而且出于许多可能很好的原因，你们把所有这些数据都内部保密。你们不会跟我们这些为你们制作内容的人分享。你们会暗示，你知道的，这节目表现挺好或者也许不太好，但实际上基本上就是：如果表现不好，它就没了。但如果表现足够好，能留下来，它就留下来。不会有什么咬牙切齿的争论，比如“天哪，今天或明天的收视率上升还是下降了”。
There's sort of a, all of that kind of nonsense is taken out of it and things just really exist on the merits, which I think the audience picks up on as well. And sometimes, you know, relative to what it costs to make a TV show or a movie, sometimes you don't get enough people to watch it. And eventually, if you do that too often, you don't have enough money to make new shows. So the balance of this is just relative to what it costs. Can we get people to show up? Maybe what's unique about this relative to TV is, you know, it costs X amount of money
所有这些无聊的杂音都被去掉了，节目完全凭实力说话，我觉得观众也能体会到这一点。有时候，你知道的，相对于制作一档电视节目或电影的成本来说，有时你吸引不到足够多的人来观看。最终，如果你经常这样做，你就没有足够的资金去制作新节目了。所以这其中的平衡，仅仅是相对于成本而言。我们能吸引观众来看吗？也许这与传统电视不同独特的地方在于，你知道的，制作半小时的网络电视节目
to make a half hour of network television and everyone has to like it. And this has got to be like, you know, we can make a show for a couple hundred thousand people. If it's economically sensible, we can make a show for a hundred million people if it's economically sensible. One thing that we get to look at sometimes it's super helpful is among the people who push play. So there's a million reasons that sometimes the show just doesn't connect with the public
需要花费 X 金额，而且每个人都必须喜欢它。而对于我们来说，可以是，你知道的，如果经济上合理，我们可以为几十万人制作一个节目；如果经济上合理，我们也可以为一亿人制作一个节目。我们有时能看到的一个非常有用的小地方是，在那些点击播放的人当中。所以，有时节目只是没有与公众建立联系的原因有一百万个，
and nobody, everyone missed a great show. But among the people who push play, did they like it? And if you like it enough to watch the whole thing, did they watch four episodes in one night because they couldn't go to sleep because they loved it so much? Those are really positive signals, even if the big audience didn't show up in the first season that we used to make that second season decision. So Ted, so like a lot of your competitors that I remember a few years ago, when they first started making noise about to Jason's point about not releasing your numbers.
没人看，所有人都错过了一部好节目。但在那些点击播放的人当中，他们喜欢它吗？如果你喜欢到能把整整一集看完，他们是不是因为太喜欢了而一晚上看了四集，连觉都舍不得睡？这些都是非常积极的信号，即使第一季没有吸引到庞大的受众，我们也可以用这些信号来做出续订第二季的决定。所以，泰德，就像你的很多竞争对手一样，我记得几年前，当他们刚开始对杰森关于不公开收视数据的观点大做文章时。
And there were a few people who, who ran other networks who were almost beside themselves about the fact that you wouldn't release it. And we know that because what they actually said publicly, they were almost beside themselves. Can you imagine how they were privately and they were so pissed and your language in dealing with it was so great because you were just like, yeah, I know people are mad, but we're just not going to do it. And how did that feel to you? Well, the funny thing was, I wasn't, we're not trying to be secretive of it.
有几个其他电视网的负责人几乎对你们不愿公开数据这件事感到抓狂。我们知道这一点，因为他们公开说的话表明他们几乎快气疯了。你能想象他们私底下是什么样吗？他们气坏了，而你应对时的措辞真是太棒了，因为你当时就像是在说：“是的，我知道大家很生气，但我们就是不打算这么做。”你当时感觉如何？好吧，有趣的是，我并不是，我们并不是想保密。
I just don't think it's an apples to apples thing when we say how many people watch a show on Netflix versus how many people watch it on the network and on day one. So if you're selling advertising for a movie that's going to open this weekend, how many people saw your ad on Thursday night is usually valuable information. And it correlates to the fee. You're going to charge crest, crest toothpaste to run your 32nd ad. If it's on a show that's watched by 30 million people, you're going to have to pay X for that 32nd ad.
我只是认为，当我们说有多少人在 Netflix 上观看某部节目，与有多少人在电视网上观看某部节目、而且是在首播当天观看时，这并不是一种同类对比。所以，如果你在为一部将于本周末上映的电影出售广告，那么有多少人在周四晚上看到了你的广告，通常是很有价值的信息。而且这与你要向佳洁士牙膏收取的费用息息相关，如果你要投放你的30秒广告。如果它是一个有3000万人观看的节目，你就要为那个30秒广告支付 X 费用的广告费。
10 million people. That's why. Yeah. And because our business doesn't, we're not selling toothpaste for press, it's irrelevant in the same way. So over time, I think there is a measurement of, is this show relevant to the culture or enough people watching it for me to think about it? And that's how you see us being much more open about, you know, in the first 28 days,
1000万人。这就是原因。对。而且因为我们的业务不需要，我们不是在帮佳洁士卖牙膏，所以这种对比在同等意义上是无关紧要的。因此，随着时间的推移，我认为存在一种衡量标准，即：这个节目是否与文化相关？是否有足够多的人在看它，值得我考虑？这就是为什么你会看到我们对以下事情更加开放，你知道的，比如在前28天里，
that's millions of people watch this show and that show, because I do think it's a bit of a cultural measure, not a business measure, but also even practically speaking for you guys, when you're hearing that pitch, you can go back to your office. You can say, okay, so this is a show about auto racing in, you know, Iowa. And you can look on your, you're right. I mean, it's a great show already. And you can look at your internal metrics and say, how many of our subscribers love stuff about Iowa and cars, and you go, well, that's a million people.
有数百万人在观看这档或那档节目，因为我确实认为这是一种文化层面的衡量标准，而不是商业层面的。但从实际角度来看，对于你们来说，当你们听到这个推销时，你们可以回到办公室。你们可以说，好吧，所以这是一个关于爱荷华州赛车的故事。然后你们可以查看你们的，你说得对。我的意思是，这已经是一个很棒的节目了。你们可以查看你们的内部指标，然后说，我们的订阅用户中有多少人喜欢关于爱荷华州和汽车的内容？你们会说，嗯，有一百万人。
And so a million people paying 17 bucks a month for the subscription, would that justify the presumed budget of this show? I mean, I know it's not as simplistic as that, but that's kind of at the core of what you're trying to manage in your mind about whether to make the investment of the show or not, whether it's right for your subscribers or not, correct? All those indicators, yeah. And then every once in a while, something just comes out of the blue, like a Queens Gambit.
所以有一百万用户每个月支付17美元的订阅费，这是否能证明这部节目的预计预算是合理的？我的意思是，我知道事情没那么简单，但这正是你脑海中试图权衡的核心问题，即是否要对这部节目进行投资，它是否适合你们的订阅用户，对吧？所有这些指标，是的。然后每隔一段时间，就会有一些意想不到的爆款出现，比如《后翼弃兵》。
Nope. There was no data that says chest lovers and this period chess piece is going to be the most watched show on television. By the way, Ted, Queens Gambit was great. I could have used less chess. You know what I mean? That's your note. It was a little heavy on chess.
不。没有任何数据表明国际象棋爱好者和这个时期的国际象棋题材会成为电视上观看人数最多的节目。顺便说一句，泰德，《后翼弃兵》太棒了。不过里面的国际象棋镜头少一点就好了。你知道我的意思吗？这就是你的意见。里面的国际象棋元素有点太多了。
It was a little, was a little, honestly, I didn't know till the last episode it was about chess. You didn't even realize. I was like, what is this game? And then I bought a board and I'm in. Now I'm in. It's kind of like checkers, right, Sean? Yeah.
元素有点，说实话，直到最后一集我才知道它是关于国际象棋的。你甚至都没意识到。我当时还在想：这到底是什么游戏？然后我买了一副棋盘，我就入坑了。现在我彻底入坑了。这有点像西洋跳棋，对吧，肖恩？对。
It's just a little bit checkers. It's on the other side of the checkerboard. Yeah. Just flip it over. It's like, like the underworld and stranger things or whatever it is. Okay. So my question is, um, back to my kind of original thing. So in your opinion, how long do you think the network system can sustain itself before
它只是有点像西洋跳棋。它在棋盘的另一面。Yeah。把它翻过来就行。就像《怪奇物语》里的逆世界或者别的什么。好吧。所以我的问题是，呃，回到我最初的那个话题。所以在你看来，电视网系统还能支撑多久？
what happens before? I don't know. Like what, what do you think about that? I think the inevitable thing that happens is everyone starts bringing their original stuff to their streaming services. That means they're not going to put it on the network and it's just going to be a race to the bottom. It's going to be sports and news.
在此之前会发生什么？我不知道。比如，你怎么看这个？我认为不可避免会发生的事情是，每个人都开始将他们的原创内容带到他们自己的流媒体服务上。这意味着他们不会再把它放在电视网上，这只是一场通往底层的赛跑。最后剩下的将只有体育和新闻。
Yeah. And, you know, and you saw Amazon, but Thursday night football is buying Thursday night football. Yeah. So what does that mean? Like, so when I, so NBC CBS, ABC Fox, what's going to happen to those channels and those networks? I don't know. I mean, what we have to go.
对，你知道的，你看到了亚马逊，但周四橄榄球之夜正在收购周四橄榄球之夜。对。那这意味着什么？所以当我——所以NBC、CBS、ABC、福克斯，这些频道和电视网会怎么样？我不知道。我的意思是，我们必须走了。
Okay. Good night, everybody. One way to think about it is if you watch, I'm a, uh, I'm a big fan of, uh, we watch a lot of home and garden TV in our house. I'm a very embarrassed by the number of hours we spend doing this, but, uh, but if you watch it right now, you see, they just launched their own service called discovery plus a little pitch for them. And they have turned their network into a Barker channel for that service.
好吧，大家晚安。有一种思考方式是，如果你看，我是个——我是一个超级粉丝，呃，我们家看很多家庭和花园电视频道。我对我们花在这上面的时间感到非常尴尬，但是，但是如果你现在看它，你会发现他们刚刚推出了自己的服务，叫做 Discovery Plus，顺便帮他们打个广告。他们已经把他们的电视网变成了该服务的一个循环广告频道。
They're basically every minute you watch a discovery network on TV, they're saying, don't watch it here, watch it there. The one blessing that we've had in our business and our professional existence is we've never had to manage ourselves out of anything. You know what I mean? Like we didn't have to like, how are we going to replace our movie theater business? We didn't really have a business of people who love the theater. So for us, we've been saying, just go where the audience is and we were able to do it
基本上，你在电视上观看 Discovery 电视网的每一分钟，他们都在说：不要在这里看，去那里看吧。我们在业务和职业生涯中享有的唯一福气是，我们从来不需要靠摆脱某种困境来管理自己。你知道我的意思吗？就像我们不需要考虑：我们要如何取代我们的电影院业务？我们本来就没有什么热爱电影院的庞大业务基础。所以对我们来说，我们一直说的是：观众在哪里，我们就去哪里，而且我们能够做到
pretty nimbly. All these companies make all of their money on advertising and cable television fees are going to have to replace that with the revenue on their services and in, in, in kind of some balanced way or they're going to end up in these weird places. And anyway, I think they'll navigate it fine, but just these, these changes don't come around very often. I mean, this is the first big change that's cable TV for years ago. How have you noticed personally, to the extent you're comfortable revealing, in and around
相当敏捷。所有这些靠广告和有线电视费赚钱的公司，都必须用它们流媒体服务的收入来弥补这一缺口，并且要以某种平衡的方式进行，否则它们最终会陷入这些奇怪的境地。不管怎样，我认为他们会很好地应对，只是这些变革不会经常发生。我的意思是，这是有线电视多年来的第一次重大变革。你个人有没有注意到，在你愿意透露的范围内，在
the community, how has it evolved socially when you are at a function or a dinner with one of your colleagues that happens to be heading up, let's say one of these broadcast networks. So some of the places where you, you represent a threat to their, to their existence early on. Now actually you guys have become such leaders that it's actually buoying the whole industry and changing the model and people are having these, these, these pluses, right? These streaming services as offshoots and it's, it's, it's really elevating some of their
这个圈子里，当你和碰巧掌管这些广播电视网之一的同行参加某个活动或晚宴时，社交关系是如何演变的？在早期，你对他们的生存构成了威胁。现在，实际上你们已经成为了这样的领导者，以至于它实际上在提振整个行业，改变了模式，人们正在获得这些，这些，这些优势，对吧？这些流媒体服务作为衍生业务，它确实在提升他们的一些
business models. Are they now less sort of confrontational for lack of a better word? And are they more sort of deferential and he wants to know if people are hissing at you at parties. Are they friendlier now or, or how do you feel about all that stuff? What's it feel like out there? You guys know this town, not to my face, but you can sense it. You're really in touch and a sensitive guy.
商业模式。他们现在是不是没那么对抗了（换个更好的词），是不是更加恭敬了？他想知道人们在聚会上是不是对你发出嘘声。他们现在更友好了吗？或者你对所有这些事情有什么感觉？外面感觉怎么样？你们了解这个镇子，虽然不是当面，但你们能感觉到。你真的很懂行而且是个敏感的人。
I'm sure you can see how it's kind of ebbed and flowed. Yeah. This person acts. It was particularly annoyed by the existence of Netflix and all the changes and, you know, basically that we didn't have to put out ratings and why would they put someone from a Netflix show on the cover of a magazine? No one knows who's why. I mean, say these things very publicly.
我确信你能看出这其中是如何起伏跌宕的。是的。这个人表现得。他对 Netflix 的存在以及所有的变化感到特别恼火，你知道的，基本上是因为我们不需要公布收视率，为什么要把一个 Netflix 节目的演员放到杂志封面上？没人知道为什么。我的意思是，公开说这些话。
Right. He was very upset about it, which the irony is this person X now runs a network doing exactly that. But it comes didn't age well. Yes. But it was really the funniest story for me in my time in the business is we, there was a party, one of these night before the Emmy Awards parties and there was two parties going on next door to each other.
对。他对此非常沮丧，而讽刺的是，这个“X先生”现在经营着一家正好在做同样事情的电视网。但这并没有经受住时间的考验。是的。但对我来说，我在这一行经历过的最有趣的故事是，有一次我们去参加派对，艾美奖颁奖典礼前夜的派对之一，隔壁有两个派对同时在举行。
And one of them was the big industry party. And the other one was just for this person's network and their, and their talent. And when I walked of all people, me, I was, I'm walking in the party. I went left instead of right and walked into their party and they're all, you know, the biggest stars in town. So I thought this is the big party and, and it was their private party. And as I'm walking around, I come to the realization, Oh, this is his party, his party. So I like, it was almost like an episode of I love Lucy.
其中一个是大型行业派对。另一个只是为了这个人的电视网以及他们的，以及他们的艺人。当我走进去时，偏偏是我，我走进派对。我向左走而不是向右走，走进了他们的派对，里面全都是，你知道的，镇上最大的明星。所以我觉得这是那个大型派对，而且，这是一个私人派对。当我四处走动时，我意识到，哦，这是他的派对，他的派对。所以我就像，这几乎就像是《我爱露西》里的一集。
I'm trying to sneak out the side door. So no, it sees me in there. And then I walk around behind the outside of the party and to walk out. And I walk out across this big glass wall where he is making a speech. I'm literally walking behind him. His nightmare came true. Yeah. And person X, by the way, is so talented.
我试图从侧门溜出去。这样没人会看到我在那儿。然后我绕到派对的外侧后面准备走出去。我从一面巨大的玻璃墙前走过，他正在那里发表演讲。我简直是从他身后走过。他的噩梦成真了。对。而且顺便说一句，“X先生”非常有才华。
I mean, there's been some incredible decisions. But that brings me to like, the fact that you again, talking about like the foresight into, into this, this new world of programming with Netflix. And then you see things like Quibi or other people trying to push those boundaries further by thinking about what's next. And I know you probably hate this question, but to the guy, you, that thought of this whole thing that changed the world, do you have any kind of what's in your crystal ball next?
我的意思是，有一些令人难以置信的决策。但这让我想到了，你再次谈到了对 Netflix 这种全新编程世界的远见。然后你会看到像 Quibi 或其他人试图通过思考下一步来进一步突破这些界限。我知道你可能讨厌这个问题，但对于想出这一切并改变了世界的你来说，你的水晶球里能看到下一步是什么吗？
Like what in the world is next? You know, it's funny. Every couple of years, we're doing that thing that we didn't do before. So we started off making our first year out, right? We had House of Cards, Lily Hammer, Arrested Development. Yeah. What a show. I say both words, by the way.
这世界上到底下一步是什么？你知道，这很有趣。每隔几年，我们都在做我们以前没做过的事。所以我们刚起步的第一年，对吧？我们有《纸牌屋》、《莉莉海默》、《发展受阻》。是的。真是个好节目。顺便说一句，这两个词我都发音。
Yeah. Oh, you do that. No, because you know Ricky. You know Ricky. Ted knows it makes Ricky Jervis so crazy when I say Arrested, makes him fucking nuts. And Hemlock Grove, right? So that was our, that was our big lineup. And then after that, we started, you know, we didn't do any unscripted.
对。哦，你这么做了。不，因为你知道瑞奇。你知道瑞奇。泰德知道每当我说是 Arrested 时，都会让瑞奇·热维斯疯狂，让他气死。还有《铁杉树丛》，对吧？所以那是我们的，那是我们的强大阵容。在那之后，我们开始，你知道的，我们没有做任何无剧本节目。
We didn't do any animation. We didn't do any feature film. And we didn't do anything outside of the United States or not in English. So over the next, every two years or so since that launch in 2013, we've expanded to do all those things. And now we are, you know, producing a $200 million feature film. We're doing local language shows and about 200 local language original shows premiering this year.
我们没有做任何动画。我们没有做任何故事片。而且我们没有做任何美国以外的或非英语的内容。所以在接下来的时间里，自从2013年推出以来，大约每两年，我们都在扩展并完成所有这些事情。现在我们正在，你知道的，制作一部2亿美元的故事片。我们在制作当地语言的节目，今年将首播大约200部当地语言的原创节目。
What I wanted to get to, that's been a big part of your expansion. Well, two things. One, one was when we started making Arrested Development and Jason, you remember, we all went out to Las Vegas to make this announcement. It was very weird. We didn't really know each other at Ted at all. I mean, we'd sort of met. And then we ended up, you and I stayed with David Cross and we played, and we stayed and
我想说的是，这一直是你们扩张的很大一部分。好吧，两件事。一件是当我们开始制作《发展受阻》的时候，杰森，你还记得，我们都去拉斯维加斯发布这个消息。这很奇怪。我们当时根本不了解泰德。我的意思是，我们算是一面之交。然后结果是，你和我跟大卫·克罗斯一起待过，我们玩了，我们待过，
played craps one night. We almost cleaned the place out and we broke the bag. And we go, come on. Where was I? Was I, was I was already passed out up there? You were in bed. Yeah. With a mouthful of walnuts.
有一天晚上玩了骰子游戏。我们差点把赌场赢光了，还打破了记录。然后我们说，来吧。我当时在哪儿？我当时，我当时是不是已经在上面昏睡过去了？你在睡觉。对。满嘴都是核桃。
You were just already asleep. And so we go to. And so at that time, I will admit that when we first started having, we started hanging out and you announced the show, I had no idea. Of course, I had very little idea of what it was going to be. You had, didn't know what you guys were going to become yet. I had even less of an idea, right? And then it became, we, Arrested Development kind of happened at a time when you guys were
你当时已经睡着了。所以我们去。所以在那个时候，我得承认，当我们刚开始有，我们开始一起混，你宣布这个节目时，我一无所知。当然，我对它会变成什么样知之甚少。你当时也不知道你们会变成什么样。我甚至了解得更少，对吧？然后它变成了，我们，《发展受阻》发生的时候，你们正好
rocketing, your business was really expanding quickly. But I was going to say. Why didn't we ask for stock instead of cash? Because we're so stupid. God, we're dumb. Because you got in there is why. Bullshit. It wasn't my fault.
蓬勃发展，你们的业务扩张得非常快。但我本来想说。我们当时为什么不要求要股票而不是现金？因为我们太蠢了。天哪，我们太笨了。因为你加入了，这就是原因。胡扯。这不是我的错。
It wasn't a deal. You did like a fucking moron. Imagine how rich we would be today. Imagine if we'd just listened to our lawyers and not Bateman. So anyway, we go to, but I was going to say it's so Ted, cut to a couple of years later, we do Bojack. And I want you to quickly tell the story about how Bojack came to be in a minute. But we go to, do you remember that time we went to Europe?
这不是一笔好买卖。你就像个大笨蛋一样。想象一下我们今天会有多富有。想象一下如果我们当时听了律师的话而不是贝特曼的。所以不管怎样，我们去，但我本想说，泰德，快进到几年后，我们做了《马男波杰克》。我想让你简单讲讲《马男波杰克》是如何诞生的故事。但我们去，你还记得我们去欧洲的那次吗？
I had just done the first season of Flaked and we went to Europe to promote Netflix. You were opening in France. So we went to Madrid and we went to Italy and we went to Paris. And you and Reed gave all these great speeches in front of people, but I remember distinctly. So we're in like, I guess we're in Milan and all these reporters going, oh, why should we care about Netflix? What's it going to do? And I said to them clearly, I want you to remember saying this to me now, a year from
我刚拍完第一季的《流浪富豪》，我们去欧洲宣传 Netflix。你当时要在法国开业。所以我们去了马德里，去了意大利，去了巴黎。你和里德在大家面前发表了所有这些精彩的演讲，但我清楚地记得。所以我们在，我想我们在米兰，所有这些记者都在问，哦，我们为什么要关心 Netflix？它能做什么？我当时对他们说得很清楚，我希望你们现在记住一年前对我说的这些话。
now. And of course it becomes true and Netflix goes and it explodes in all these countries and it becomes the thing. And part of that, this is a huge question so long, I'm bored myself. Yeah, it is. It's Tuesday. You made all these local productions in every country that you went to, that became a big part of your success.
当然这一切都成真了，Netflix 随后在所有这些国家爆发，并成为了现象级存在。其中一部分，这是一个很大的问题，说了太久，我自己都觉得无聊了。是的，确实是。今天是星期二。你在你去的每个国家都制作了所有这些本地作品，这成为了你成功的重要部分。
It's very big. And what's cool about it is they get watched everywhere, including in the U.S. So our watching of non-English television has grown 50% year in year. And things like, you know, Korean drama has grown 100% in the U.S. Huge, huge. And you know how much I love those European shows. I told you years ago, and then you'll text me and say, we've got a new show coming out. You've got to check it out now, you know.
这非常重要。酷炫的地方在于它们到处都被观看，包括在美国。因此，我们对非英语电视节目的观看量年同比增长了50%。像，你知道的，韩剧在美国增长了100%。巨大，巨大。你知道我有多喜欢那些欧洲节目。我多年前就告诉过你，然后你会发短信给我说，我们有一部新节目要上映了，你现在得去看看，你知道的。
Totally. So far we've been chatting with Ted Serrano, CEO. I would like to chat with Theodore. Oh, yes. Oh my gosh, here we go. This is where he makes you cry. Here you go, favorite color. Get ready.
完全正确。到目前为止，我们一直在和 CEO 泰德·萨兰多斯聊天。我想和西奥多聊聊。哦，耶。哦，天哪，来了。这就是他让你哭的地方。来吧，最喜欢的颜色。准备好。
That was a very smooth transition. Take us back to Arizona. What were you driving to the video store? Was it, let me make a guess here. Was it a 320i? Was it, was it a Jetta or was it a Datsun B210? And was there a mullet? There was, there was not a mullet, but there may have been a Ford F-150 pickup.
这是一个非常顺畅的过渡。带我们回到亚利桑那州。你当时开车去录像带租赁店开的是什么车？是这样的，让我猜猜。是一辆 320i 吗？是一辆，是一辆捷达，还是一辆 Datsun B210？而且当时有鲻鱼头（前短后长发型）吗？没有，没有鲻鱼头，但可能有一辆福特 F-150 皮卡。
There we go. Oh, there you go. This was Phoenix, Arizona. Jason. Is this, are you doing the thing you've dreamed of doing? If not, what is that dream? How much longer can you do this? Do you get burnt out?
那就对了。哦，原来如此。这是亚利桑那州的凤凰城。杰森。这是，你现在做的是你一直梦想做的事情吗？如果不是，那个梦想是什么？你还能做多久？你会精疲力竭吗？
What else do you want to do? I am doing way beyond what I could have dreamed of doing in my life. I really hold the art of making film and television in very high regard. I think it plays a critical role in people's emotional and mental health. I agree. I think it is so important what happens every day there, and I feel like being involved in it at any scale is insane. As a kid, I, for some weird reason, I needed like five hours of sleep.
你还想做什么？我做的事情远远超出了我一生中梦寐以求的程度。我对电影和电视制作艺术有着非常高的评价。我认为它在人们的情感和心理健康中发挥着至关重要的作用。我同意。我认为每天在那里发生的事情太重要了，我觉得无论以何种规模参与其中都是不可思议的。小时候，我出于某种奇怪的原因，只需要大约五个小时的睡眠。
So I would be up late and I'd watched TV and, and my life, I've talked about this kind of publicly before. My, my home life was pretty chaotic when I was young. I have five brothers and sisters, very young parents, and it was kind of like there was no bedtime. There was no curfew. It was pretty crazy. Same.
所以我总是熬夜看电视，我的生活，我以前在公开场合谈论过这个。在我年轻的时候，我的家庭生活相当混乱。我有五个兄弟姐妹，父母很年轻，而且感觉就像没有睡觉时间。没有宵禁。相当疯狂。我也是。
Television brought me a sense of order. I knew what was on at 11 o'clock on channel five, and it was really important for me to have that order. It really did, it had a huge influence on me. And then, but it came through as I had a deep reverence for old things. I mean, I've seen every episode of Dick Van Dyke and Andy Griffith that shows a hundred times. I could quote them.
电视给我带来了一种秩序感。我知道5号频道11点播什么，这种秩序对我很重要。它确实对我产生了巨大的影响。然后，但它表现出来的是我对老旧事物有着深深的敬意。我的意思是，我看过每一集的《迪克·范·戴克秀》和《安迪·格里菲斯秀》上百次。我都能背出台词。
And so growing up and that's thinking about how important that was to me, I just wanted to be around it. That alone, you know, which was fine for me. You know, when I was young, the, the gauntlet, a movie from Clint Eastwood, yeah, they came to Phoenix to shoot and my parents drove me downtown and dropped me off for the day to watch them shoot the movie. And it was, anybody want a kid? Oh, completely.
所以在成长过程中，考虑到这对我是多么重要，我只是想身处其中。仅此一点，你知道的，这对我来说就足够了。你知道，在我年轻的时候，克林特·伊斯特伍德的电影《警探威龙》，是的，他们来到凤凰城拍摄，我的父母开车把我送到市中心，把我放下让我呆上一整天看他们拍电影。那真是，有人想要孩子吗？哦，完全是。
And it was the hottest day in Arizona history. I don't think they gave me any money for a drink, even there's a, but, but they are I sat out there all day and watched them shoot and my, my tennis shoes, like we're literally melted on the street or so hot that day and, and it was just to get a glimpse of this magic that was happening. And I, and I don't know, I probably still have them somewhere, but I collected some of the old shells where they were shooting at the bus and all that. And it's just to me, it's like I got close to the gods that day.
那是亚利桑那州历史上最热的一天。我想他们甚至没给我买饮料的钱，即使有一个，但，但我在那儿坐了一整天看他们拍戏，我的网球鞋，就像在街上真的融化了一样，那天实在太热了，这只是为了看一眼正在发生的那种魔法。而且，我不知道，我可能还在某个地方留着它们，我收集了一些他们朝公共汽车射击时掉落的旧弹壳。对当时的我觉得，那一天我离神明很近。
And then so to, to me, Sean, when you say, are you doing what you want to do beyond beyond. But also changing it to a way that, that, that you kind of saw maybe even in a young age, uh, where it was kind of missing and where it could become better. I love what you said. I read somewhere that were you, you got tired of, of sleeping too late on Saturday and missing your cartoons. Yeah. So the sense that you could have that on demand at some point, maybe was, was lodging on and
所以对我来说，肖恩，当你问，你做的是你想做的事吗？这已经超越了超越。但也把它改变成了一种，你可能甚至在很小的时候就看到的某种形式，呃，那种它有所欠缺并且可以变得更好的地方。我喜欢你刚才说的话。我读到过某篇文章说，你厌倦了星期六睡得太晚而错过你的动画片。是的。所以那种你可以随时点播的感觉，在某种程度上，可能就扎根在心里了，
then also watching, uh, all the Mary Hartman's, uh, back to back to back to back on a Sunday night, uh, after they aggregated at that, on that day, that was my first binge. Right. Exactly. So that that wouldn't be a negative when that became, uh, a possibility for you guys. It's funny. My kids are 26 and 24. And I try to get them to understand that there was a time that, like you said, if you slept
然后还有在星期天晚上，连续不断地看所有的《玛丽·哈特曼》，在它们在那一天汇总播出之后，那是我第一次熬夜狂看。对。没错。所以当这成为你们的一种可能性时，这绝不是一件负面的事。有趣的是，我的孩子26岁和24岁。我试图让他们理解，曾经有过这样一个时代，就像你说的，如果你在星期六睡
in on Saturday, you missed cartoons that way the whole week, uh, you know, if you didn't see a show on prime time, you had to wait 20 years to see it again. Right. Right. Yeah. So you, not only when you have a new show this week and you go, you know, you can watch it whenever you get around to it, but you're also, when you come on against other shows new this week, you're also coming on against everything ever made.
懒觉，你就会错过动画片，那样整个星期，呃，你知道的，如果你错过了黄金时段的节目，你必须等20年才能再次看到它。对。对。是的。所以，当你这周有新节目上线时，不仅观众可以随时观看，而且当你与这周其他新节目同台竞技时，你其实也是在与有史以来制作过的一切内容同台竞技。
Yeah. Yeah. So it's like, it's a very strange dynamic. And I think the relationship people have with programming, all kinds of storytelling is so different. Think about a movie. Our relationship with movies used to be movies were huge, right? They were bigger, that way bigger than us and they were totally in control.
对。对。所以这是一种非常奇怪的动态关系。而且我认为人们与节目、各种讲故事方式之间的关系是如此不同。想想电影。我们过去与电影的关系是，电影曾经是巨大的，对吧？它们比我们大得多，而且它们完全处于掌控之中。
If the movie started eight o'clock, you better be in your seat at eight o'clock or you're going to miss the beginning. Right. And if they said something that you missed, you had to buy a ticket and come back in two hours when they say it again. And now movies are smaller than us generally and we control when they stop and start. And I don't, it's interesting thing to me that with the relationship to, to storytelling and listening and all those things, how that evolves over time when that relationship is
如果电影八点钟开始，你最好八点钟坐在座位上，否则你就会错过开头。对。如果他们说了什么你没听清的话，你必须买票并在两个小时后他们再次播放时回来。而现在电影总体上比我们小，我们控制它们的暂停和开始。而且我不，对我来说这是一件有趣的事情，随着与讲故事、倾听所有这些事情的关系的发展，当这种关系
so dramatically different than it used to be. Yeah. Well, also it's funny you said that we do now measure everything sort of apples to apples. Like you can watch a show and say, Hey, I watched this comedy and then somebody go, Yeah, but it's not as good as the wire. And you're saying, well, yeah, of course it's different. Like this operates over here and this lives over here. And now you, everybody just compares everything to everything, the question you ask each other,
与过去相比发生了如此巨大的变化时。是的。嗯，这也是个有趣的现象，你提到我们现在确实在进行同类对比。就像你可以看一个节目然后说，嘿，我看这部喜剧，然后有人说，是的，但它不如《火线》。而你会说，嗯，是的，当然它们不同。就像这个在这里运作，那个生活在那里。而现在，每个人都把所有东西和所有东西进行比较，你们互相问的问题，
we all ask our friends and we get asked of each other is, what are you watching? What have you seen lately? I think one thing that doesn't get mentioned enough. A recent development in that first season of new content on Netflix, why it's so kind of symbolically important is when we first started the DVD business, people would just try box set television, but we started seeing how people watch TV shows like that because they're watching, you know, three or four episodes on a disc and then changing disc really fast.
我们都会问我们的朋友，而且我们也会被别人问到的是：你在看什么？你最近看了什么？我认为有一点没有得到足够的提及。这种新内容在 Netflix 第一季中的最新发展，之所以在象征意义上如此重要，是因为当我们刚开始做 DVD 业务时，人们只是尝试电视盒装剧集，但我们开始看到人们是如何观看这类电视节目的，因为他们在看，你知道的，一张光盘上有三四集，然后换光盘的速度非常快。
They really got into it. And then we started streaming the only things that the networks would sell us were things that were not sold in this indication. That arrested development had just come off of the network that year and they didn't have four seasons. So it hadn't been sold, hadn't been syndicated. So arrested development was one of the first things we had on Netflix to stream. And it was literally a completely different experience to watch arrested development four
他们真的沉迷进去了。然后我们开始流媒体播放，电视网肯卖给我们的只有那些没有在联合电视台出售的东西。那部《发展受阻》刚好在那一年刚离开电视网，而且他们没有四季。所以它没有被卖掉，没有进行联合播出。因此，《发展受阻》是我们首批在 Netflix 上流媒体播放的节目之一。连续观看四
or five episodes at a time. Because as you guys know, Mitch will write a joke that sets up an episode two and pays off an episode seven. And there's a 30, 40% chance you are not going to see episode seven if you're watched episode two. So on Netflix, people watch the show in its entirety in a complete straight sitting and realize the genius of this comedy, how it was written, how it pays off, the complexity, the multiple, how many storylines, how many characters, how many jokes can all be running
或五集《发展受阻》完全是一种截然不同的体验。因为正如你们所知，米奇会写一个在第二集埋下伏笔并在第七集回收的笑话。如果你只看了第二集，你有30%到40%的概率是看不到第七集的。所以在 Netflix 上，人们一口气完整地看完整部剧，并意识到这部喜剧的天才之处，它是如何编写的，它是如何呼应的，它的复杂性，多重性，有多少条故事线，有多少个角色，有多少个笑话可以同时进行。
at the same time. Cause you needn't waste any time repeating exposition because you can assume the audience just finished watching that episode. Nobody missed the reference. Nobody risked the reference. I was taking from that. And I remember kind of the conversations leading into that fourth season, the first Netflix season of arrested, arrested that Mitch would development.
因为你不需要浪费任何时间重复背景设定，你可以假设观众刚刚看完了那一集。没有人错过这个梗。没有人冒着错过这个梗的风险。我从中吸取了教训。我记得通往第四季（即 Netflix 第一季《发展受阻》）的那些对话，米奇将要开发的。
Have you seen it yet, Sean? I know you saw a couple of you all in. Good for you. Good for you. I saw the first three and I laughed out loud. You'd had enough. Good for you. What was my character's name?
肖恩，你看过没有？我知道你看过几集。好样的。好样的。我看过前三集，我笑出声来。你看够了。好样的。我角色的名字叫什么？
What was my character's name? What's my character's name? God. What's my character's name? I thought his character's name was Job. And then I was corrected that it's Job. Who said God? Who the fuck?
我角色的名字叫什么？我的角色叫什么名字？天哪。我的角色叫什么名字？我以为他角色的名字叫 Job。然后我被纠正说是 Gob。谁说 God 来着？谁他妈的？
God was a God. But as you know, Mitch started immediately, one of the things that he got onto was he might have been one of the first showrunners, creators, writers to write to the format. He was really into that idea. Remember how excited he was by that? He was so giddy. I mean, he's giddy all the time, but he was really, particularly giddy about that. The first time I walked in, when Mitch was writing the new season for Netflix and I walked
God 是个上帝。但如你所知，米奇立即开始，他着迷的一点是，他可能是最早几个按格式写作的剧集主管、创作者、编剧之一。他对那个想法非常感兴趣。还记得他对那个有多兴奋吗？他当时兴奋得发狂。我的意思是，他一直都很兴奋，但他对那个特别兴奋。我第一次走进去时，当米奇在为 Netflix 编写新季时，我走
in that little room that he was writing and there was index cards and color Cody yarn all around the room. The string. Yeah. The string of plots. It was insane. It was so amazing. So that is an incredible comic bind, but I think in general, I'd say that usually when
进了他写作的小房间，房间周围全都是索引卡和彩色编码的纱线。那根线。是的。剧情的线索。太疯狂了。太棒了。所以这是一个不可思议的喜剧结合，但我通常认为，一般当
people say things are ahead of their time, that's a nice way of saying it didn't work. But a recent development is truly ahead of its time. It's a show that was built to be binged before anyone was binging television. Yeah. So for going from a show that was ahead of its time to a show that almost never was Bojack Horseman was a 13 minute presentation that Raphael Bob Waksberg wrote and that that that I did with Aaron Paul and Paul of Tompkins and Amy Sedaris and amongst other people that Patton was in the first and everybody passed on it and they brought it to you.
人们说某些事情超前于他们的时代时，这只是在委婉地说它失败了。但《发展受阻》确实是超前于它的时代。这是一部在任何人都在追看电视之前就为一口气刷完而打造的节目。对。所以从一部超前于时代的节目到一部几乎从未问世的节目，《马男波杰克》是拉斐尔·鲍勃-瓦克斯伯格写的一份13分钟的展示案，我和亚伦·保尔、保罗·F·汤普金斯、艾米·塞达瑞斯以及帕顿等其他人一起完成了它，每个人都拒绝了它，然后他们把它带给了你。
And I remember talking to you were like, yeah, I think we're going to do it like you were literally like the last stop and you're like, it's like, really? Yeah. I think we're going to. Yeah. And you got not only did you pick it up, you got right into it. Yeah. And if you remember that first, so first of all, tell me about what it was when it when
我记得和你谈过，你们就像是，是的，我觉得我们要做了，你简直就像是最后一站，然后你说，真的吗？是的。我想我们要做了。是的。而且你不仅接手了，你还马上投入进去了。对。如果你还记得那个最初的，首先，当它
it came across your desk, Raphael's piece. Well, first of all, it's remarkably funny. Yeah. I mean, the show and it was had real meat on the bone. I mean, it wasn't just silly, funny. It was funny with a really serious comedy about depression, which is not on TV. And if it was, it probably wasn't funny or was to getting that balance right is really tough.
来到你的案头时，拉斐尔的作品是什么样的？首先，它非常搞笑。我的意思是，这个节目真的很有料。我的意思是，它不仅仅是愚蠢的搞笑。它是一部带有非常严肃的关于抑郁症的喜剧，这在电视上是没有的。如果有的话，它可能也不好笑，或者要掌握好那种平衡真的很难。
And that show did. Right. It was unusual in that way. And I remember at your old offices, do you remember like this first season, forget what episode it was, but one night you and I went for dinner and then you're like, hey, I just got the rough in the rough animatic of like episode five. And then we kind of looked at you and you said, let's go to my office and watch it. And we went, you remember, we went watching in the old screening room there.
而那个节目做到了。对，它在这一点上很不寻常。我还记得在你们旧的办公室里，你还记得第一季吗，忘了是哪一集了，但有一天你和我去吃晚饭，然后你说，嘿，我刚拿到第五集的粗剪动画片。然后我们看着你，你说，去我办公室看吧。我们去了，你还记得，我们在那里的旧审片室里看。
And we were both so excited about that before it even came out. We were really excited about it. That's never had that great hallucination animation sequence. That's what we were dying to see. That's what it was. Yeah. Yeah. But I got to tell you, but you know, you told that story earlier about us going with the
在它甚至还没上映之前，我们俩就对此感到非常兴奋。我们真的很兴奋。从来没有过那种精彩的幻觉动画序列。那是我们渴望看到的。就是那个。对。对。但我得告诉你，你知道你刚才讲的那个我们去
Vegas. Again, this is back to that, you know, you're just, we were so green, you know, at the beginning of this. We brought everybody to the NAB convention in Las Vegas, which is where all the like the TV tech people go. Not like the press to go to, there, no one was bringing talent to the NAB convention. We did it. Maybe it was an accident.
拉斯维加斯的故事。再次重申，这回到了那一幕，你知道的，你只是，我们当时太初出茅庐了，你知道的，在刚开始的时候。我们把所有人都带到了拉斯维加斯的 NAB 大展上，那是所有电视技术人员去的地方。不是媒体去的地方，没有人在往 NAB 大展带艺人。我们去了。也许这是一个意外。
I'm sure it was, but I'm sure, but why are they bringing all the, I remember it was the whole cast of oranges, the new black, the whole cast of orange, the rest of development. And it was like a big star-studded thing at this place where all the TV tech people come. Yeah. You were just kind of winging it. Yeah. Hey, Ted, a friend of mine and I play this stupid thing where we go quick, quick, quick,
我确信是的，但我确信，但他们为什么要带所有这些，我记得那是《女子监狱》的全体演员，《发展受阻》的全体演员。那是一个众星云集的大型活动，就在电视技术人员聚集的地方。是的。你们当时只是在即兴发挥。是的。嘿，泰德，我和一个朋友玩过一个愚蠢的游戏，我们说“快，快，快”，
and you have to name like three things, but you can't think about it. You have to, you have to say it super, super fast. You cannot think about it. Right. So I'm going to ask you a question and you have to answer it super, super fast ready. Quick, quick, quick name two shows that you're watching right now on Netflix. Go fast. Super fast.
然后你必须说出大约三样东西，但你不能思考。你必须，你必须超级超级快地说出来。你不能思考。对。所以我要问你一个问题，你必须超级超级快地回答，准备好。快，快，快，说出两个你现在正在 Netflix 上看的节目。快。超级快。
Go. Kenny and Georgia and Firefly Lane. Great. That's all the time we have. Wow. Shit. Wait, wait. Now, are those the same shows that Nicole, your wife is watching or, or is she?
快。金妮与乔治亚和萤火溪。太棒了。我们今天的时间到此为止。哇。操。等等。等等。现在，这些是妮可（你妻子）在看的节目，还是说她在看别的？
That's why it was so easy for me to answer. So do you guys, do you guys, are you one of those ideal couples that watches all the same shows together? Yeah. We don't have very similar taste. I mean, Nicole does not like anything dark in any way and I do. And she really loves like a, she's a very tough customer of my wife, Nicole, so she, but she loved, she was an early spotter on Bridgerton.
这就是为什么我回答得这么轻松。那你们呢，你们俩，你们是那种会一起看所有相同节目的完美情侣吗？是的。我们的品味不太相似。我是说，妮可一点也不喜欢任何暗黑风格的东西，而我喜欢。而且她真的很喜欢……我的妻子妮可对这方面要求非常严格，不过她非常喜欢，她很早就发现了《布里杰顿》。
She knew it was going to be a hot one and the show Virgin River was one that she really loves. So one thing that our sweet spot where we agree is, is like I said, each GTV, so that's why we watch so much. So she's not cross-infecting your, your, your, your algorithm, right? She's got her own account cause Amanda is screwing mine up so badly. You guys have to, you have to set up a separate profile. You're right.
她知道这部剧会大火，而《维琴河》也是她非常喜欢的剧集。所以我们俩能达成一致的甜蜜点，就像我说的，就是各自看电视，所以我们才看了那么多。所以她不会污染你的算法对吧？她有自己的账户，因为阿曼达把我的算法搞得一团糟。你们得设置一个独立的个人资料。你说得对。
That's the key. Right. Because for us, it's the same thing. We will watch four hours of Virgin River and then Nicole goes to bed and I watched six hours of the Chappelle show. Right. I don't think Netflix knows anything about that. Jason, just get another account.
这才是关键。对吧。因为对我们来说也是一样的。我们会连看四个小时的《维琴河》，然后妮可去睡觉，我就看六个小时的《查佩尔秀》。对吧。我觉得奈飞对此一无所知。杰森，去弄个别的账户吧。
Don't tip Ted. Jesus Christ, man. Don't be such a cheap dick. Just get another fucking account for your wife so that she can, and don't tip Ted by having 80 people with the same password and all this BS that you always show off about. Listen, if I had stock, I would protect my profits. You know, my favorite thing about, my favorite thing about Nicole is when she admitted to me years ago, well, she said in front of you about how much stuff she gets from Amazon
别给特德出馊主意。天哪，老兄。别这么小气。给你老婆去开个他妈的独立账户，好让她能……别老是搞什么八十个人共用一个密码这种破事来占特德便宜。听着，我要是有股票，我得保护自己的利润。你知道我最喜欢妮可什么吗？我最喜欢的是几年前她向我坦白时，或者她在你面前说的，她从亚马逊买回来多少东西
and she's like, I don't give a shit. No, Nicole was buying DVDs from Amazon of movies that are on Netflix. Now was it pulling teeth to get, to get a little window to do a little Ted time today or, or is she, what's, what's it like over there in your personal world? Do you live in a prison or is she, does she, does she give it up? No, she, you know, she, I think really appreciates that the time when I, when I need to go off and do something. Yeah.
然后她说，我才不在乎呢。不，妮可竟然在亚马逊上买那些奈飞上就能看的电影的DVD。现在，要想今天能抽出一点小小的“特德时间”是不是跟拔牙一样难，还是说……你们的私人世界是怎么样的？你生活在监狱里吗？还是说她会大方地放手？不，她，你知道的，我觉得她真的很感激我需要离开去忙事情的时候。是的。
I mean, the thing about this pandemic and that's being locked in the office, I go to the office now a couple of days a week at her request. Sure. Sure. I had a good buddy, I had a good buddy who said, when this pandemic was a few months in, he said, my marriage wasn't built for 24 hours a day. No, none of them were. None of them were.
我的意思是，关于这场大流行病，还有被锁在办公室里，我现在应她的要求每周去办公室几天。当然。当然。我有一个好哥们，在大流行病持续了几个月的时候他说，我的婚姻可不是为了每天24小时相处而建立的。是的，没有谁的婚姻是这样的。没有谁是这样的。
So she was, I said, I'm going to do this tomorrow. Oh, great. And she'll, I assure you, she's, I do bring a little bit of a hectic energy to the place and she appreciates the distance sometimes. Sure. Well, we won't take you away from her any longer. Yeah. She was very jealous when I told her who I was going to be talking to tonight.
所以她当时……我说我明天要去办公室。哦，太好了。我向你保证，我确实会给家里带去一种有点狂躁的活力，有时候她很感激这种距离感。当然。好吧，我们不再占用你和她在一起的时间了。是的。当我告诉她今晚我要和谁聊天时，她嫉妒得不得了。
She said, and she left out. Yeah. We love her. And I've got to tell you, you know, a lot of people, I've heard a lot of folks throughout the quarantine saying how much Netflix, it was so important to them. But I have to tell you, prior to the quarantine was not, I did not listen to a lot of podcasts. I just didn't, I don't, I don't have a long commute. You and us both.
她说，而且她真的很激动。是的。我们爱她。我得告诉你，你知道的，很多人，我听隔离期间的很多人说奈飞对他们有多么重要。但我必须告诉你，在隔离之前，我并不怎么听播客。我只是不听，我没有很长的通勤时间。你我都是如此。
And what did I get into? I mean, of course, because my three great friends have this great podcast and I obsessively listened to every episode of smart list. I think it's, I love what you guys are doing. The only thing I like better than someone who I love when they're, I guess, is what it's someone I don't know much about. Yeah. And you guys have so much fun with them.
我怎么开始听的呢？我的意思是，当然是因为我的三个好朋友有这个超棒的播客，我疯狂地听了《聪明糊涂虫》的每一集。我觉得这太棒了，我喜欢你们在做的事情。除了我喜欢听我喜欢的人说话之外，我更喜欢听那些我不太了解的人说话。是的。而且你们和他们玩得太开心了。
And I really enjoyed it. Thank you for doing this. Oh, good. Thanks, buddy. Yeah. Very cool. Thank you, Ted, for being here. Absolutely, Sean.
我真的很享受。谢谢你们做这个。哦，太好了。谢谢，老兄。是的。非常酷。谢谢你来这里，特德。当然，肖恩。
Good to see you. Great to see you, man. It's so good to see you, Ted. You guys too. Have a good one. All right, pal. See you, buddy. Have a good day.
很高兴见到你。很高兴见到你，老兄。很高兴见到你，特德。你们也是。祝你们过得愉快。好的，伙计。回见，老兄。祝你有愉快的一天。
Bye-bye. Bye, buddy. Boy, that Ted. You know, here's the thing about Ted. We all know, and even to our listeners too, everybody knows bosses in the world, right? Everybody knows a boss works with a boss, but like Ted is so rare in that he's like you said, Jason, so personable and so likable and so jolly and so supportive. And he, he never, you never see him in a bad mood.
拜拜。再见，老兄。天哪，那个特德。你知道，关于特德是这样的。我们都知道，甚至我们的听众也知道，世界上到处都是老板，对吧？每个人都知道跟老板共事是什么样，但特德非常罕见，正如你所说，杰森，他那么平易近人，那么讨人喜欢，那么开朗，那么支持他人。而且他……你永远见不到他心情不好的时候。
Yeah. I really, I was really sincere about that at the beginning. Like I just don't know how he manages his time being so inviting to everybody he comes across. Like how does he ever leave a room? I know. Sociopath. Yeah, sociopath.
是的。一开始我真的是发自内心地这么说。我真不知道他是怎么管理时间的，对遇到的每个人都那么热情。他到底是怎么离开一个房间的？我知道。反社会者。是的，反社会者。
Ted is such a, here's what we're kind of saying. Like not only is he sort of a very personal guy and quite gregarious, he's just a very even keeled guy. And so he doesn't, he never loses sight of the prize. And it's a testament to somebody who loves their job and loves the position they're in and always has, right? And came by it organically. Yeah.
特德就是这样一个人，我们想说的是。不仅是因为他是个非常随和、相当热情的人，他还极其沉稳。因此，他从未忽视过最终的目标。这证明了一个热爱自己的工作、热爱自己所处的位置并且一直如此的人，对吧？而且这一切都来得很自然。是的。
What? You know what I mean? Like he's not in, he's not out of his depth at any, at any juncture. Yeah. He doesn't even ask the obvious question of, so do you want to be a writer or a director or a producer? Like he just, like he just seems so pleased and content with where he is and what he is doing and enjoying expanding that, diversifying and staying in his lane in sort of the best
什么？你知道我的意思吗？就像他在任何关头都不会显得力不从心。是的。他甚至不会问那些显而易见的问题，比如：你想当作家、导演还是制作人？他只是……看起来对自己的现状和正在做的事感到非常高兴和满足，并享受于拓展业务、多元化发展，同时在自己的领域里做到最好
possible version of what I'm saying. Right. I knew you were going to say that. I knew you were going to say that. Yeah. You like to know where everybody is. I didn't say lane each day. I will continue to win.
可能的最完美状态。没错。我就知道你要这么说。我就知道你会这么说。是的。你喜欢知道每个人的位置。我没说每天都在自己的领域。我会继续赢下去。
Why does he stand in his lane? Do you think he's got a sexy indifference? Oh, God. Damn it. Oh, no. You know what? I think we're spending too much time together. No, we're not.
他为什么非要坚守自己的领域？你觉得他有一种性感的冷漠吗？哦，天哪。该死。哦，不。你知道吗？我觉得我们花在一起的时间太多了。不，我们没有。
Wait. Can I ask you a question though? What is highway rhyme with? Bye. Oh, shit. That's it. Bye. But that's it.
等等。不过我能问你个问题吗？Highway（高速公路）押韵的词是什么？Bye（再见）。哦，该死。就是这个。Bye。但就是这样。
Oh, wait, wait, wait. No, no, no. Hang on. No, I'm going to throw a veto on that. Hang on. Wait, wait, wait. This highway does not rhyme with bye way. No, you got to do better than that.
哦，等等，等等，等等。不，不，不。等一下。不，我要对这个进行一票否决。等一下。等等，等等，等等。这个 highway 不跟 bye way 押韵。不，你得想个更好的。
Yeah. No, you're right. So we'll just buy that back. So we just... No, I don't think we're done talking about Ted yet. Is that the first ever aborted way? Yeah, definitely. Okay, so what we didn't get to with Ted...
对。不，你说得对。那我们把这个收回。所以我们……不，我觉得我们还没聊够特德呢。这是史上第一个被废弃的梗吗？是的，绝对是。好吧，所以我们还没跟特德聊到的是……
Was Netflix and Chill, which I wanted to get to, which you still don't fully understand. Am I right, grandpa? I don't know what that is. It's a sex thing, right? Or a code for... Oh, for fuck's sake. This is so fucking embarrassing. How do you leave the house?
那就是 Netflix and Chill（奈飞与放松），我想聊这个，但你到现在还是不太懂。我说的对吗，老头子？我不知道那是什么。那是跟性有关的事，对吧？或者是某种暗号……哦，他妈的。这太他妈尴尬了。你是怎么出门的？
What is Netflix and Chill? Okay, so Sean's equally dumb. Okay. We're smart less. Okay. You know what, I might just include my parents on this, too, so I just don't have to explain it four times. I'll just knock all four of you out at once.
什么是 Netflix and Chill？好吧，看来肖恩同样是个小白。好吧。我们可是“聪明糊涂虫”。好吧。你知道吗，我可能也得把我父母算进来，这样我就不用解释四遍了。我一口气把你们四个全干掉得了。
Yeah, we're listening to the only smart guy in the world. Go ahead, Will. So Netflix and Chill is a way... It's not necessarily a sex thing, but it's a term that people use to say, hey, why don't you come over and hang with me and we'll watch Netflix and Chill. It's kind of like the old-timey, like, hey, let's make out and watch TV. Okay. It's like, hey, let me show you my apartment.
对，我们在听世界上唯一的聪明人说话。继续吧，威尔。所以 Netflix and Chill 的意思……它不一定是一件跟性有关的事，但它是人们用来表达“嘿，要不要来我家跟我一起待会儿，我们看 Netflix 并放松一下”的一个词。这有点像老派的说法，比如“嘿，我们一边看电视一边亲热吧”。好吧。这就像是“嘿，让我给你看看我的公寓”。
Come on up. Let me show you around. That's like the old code for, come on, once you're in, then I can just kind of lock the door. Let me show you around my apartment? What the fuck? This is when you're picking up straight, like behind a dumpster? What's going on?
上楼来吧。让我带你参观一下。这就好比是那种老套的暗号，上来吧，一旦你进来了，我就可以把门锁上了。让我带你参观我的公寓？什么鬼？这是你在垃圾桶后面勾搭直男时用的吗？这到底是怎么回事？
Let me introduce you guys to the gay world. We don't say that. We just say, hey, do you want to hook up? Oh. Like, why Netflix and Chill? Well, because... You don't have a Hulu thing, though, isn't it? Oh.
让我向你们介绍一下同志世界。我们不这么说。我们直接问：嘿，你想约吗？哦。为什么叫 Netflix and Chill？因为……你们不是也有个 Hulu 的梗吗，对吧？哦。
Because I've always wondered what Hulu means. Is it a derivative from hook up, its H and the U and no? I think so. So wait, I want to say that I think we're always fascinated, like, to go back to what Jason said about the foresight of, like, I think we're endlessly fascinated with people who seemingly can see into the future and predict anything, like any kind of scientist or in this case, this programming genius about Netflix is like, how did you know that? How did you...
因为我一直想知道 Hulu 是什么意思。它是从 hook up（约炮）演变而来的吗？取了 H 和 U，不是吗？我想是的。所以等等，我想说的是，我们总是对一些事感到着迷，就像回到杰森刚才说的关于先见之明，我觉得我们对那些似乎能预见未来并预测一切的人着迷不已，比如任何科学家，或者在这个案例中，关于奈飞的这个编程天才，就像：你是怎么知道的？你是怎么……
And the risk and the timing, it's just always fascinating to me. Yeah. And right at the beginning, you'd see that stock and you'd say, oh, gosh, what are they going to do? I just... I want to... I want to sell that, you know? But, like, today, if you saw a bunch of stock, what would you say?
还有风险和时机，这对我来说总是充满魅力。是的。而在刚开始的时候，你看到那种股票，你会想，哦天哪，他们要做什么？我只是……我想……我想把股票卖掉，你知道吗？但是，今天，如果你看到一堆股票，你会说什么？
You wouldn't say sell, you'd say, bye, bye. That's how you do it, fuckface. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
你不会说卖出，你会说，拜拜。混蛋，你就是这么干的。这个集数还没有评论。点击剧本中的任意句子即可发表评论。